rapporteur mes chers collègues nous
poursuivons donc ce matin les auditions
de la mission d'information que notre
commission a décidé de constituer sur la
création du fond Marianne
la sélection des projets subventionnés
le contrôle de la réédition et les
résultats obtenus au regard des
objectifs du fond cette mission
d'information a obtenu du Sénat vous le
savez de bénéficier des prérogatives des
commissions d'enquêtes nous entendons
donc ce matin monsieur Cyril car une
garant président de l'Union des sociétés
d'éducation physique et de préparation
militaire un raccourci USA ppm je vous
précise que Monsieur Mohamed Sifaoui
directeur des opérations de la même
association n'a pu se rendre disponible
ce matin ce qu'il a expliqué par des
raisons de santé nous attendons
d'ailleurs de sa part les justificatifs
nécessaires pour reprogrammer son
audition
nous attendons donc de votre audition
monsieur le Président que vous nous
présentiez votre association son champ
de compétences et la manière dont vous
avez répondu à l'appel de projet et fond
Marianne ainsi que le rôle que vous
exercez dans cette opération vous nous
indiquerez également le son des actions
que vous avez menées pour répondre aux
objectifs du fond mariage avant de vous
céder la parole pour un bref propos
introductif je dois vous rappeler qu'un
faux témoignage devant une commission
d'enquête est passible de sanctions
pénales qui peuvent aller selon les
circonstances de 3 à 7 ans prisonnement
et de 45 000 à 100.000 euros d'amende
je vous invite à prêter sûrement de dire
toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levait la main droite et dites je le
jure
merci je vous laisse donc maintenant à
présent la parole alors faites attention
au temps ça passe assez vite 5 minutes
pour nous faire d'abord une première
synthèse après on reviendrons bien sûr
par nos questions sur l'ensemble de du
sujet c'est le président
le micro peut-être n'est pas branché
vous m'entendez maintenant
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur général mesdames et messieurs
je vous remercie de me recevoir et de
l'opportunité que vous me donnez de
m'exprimer devant vous et devant
l'opinion publique
en dehors des pressions et des
emballements médiatiques auxquels j'ai
résisté par conviction
il s'agit ici de ma première prise de
parole publique qui nécessite selon moi
de rappeler en préambule les
circonstances et déroulements exactes
des faits
je vais commencer par présenter
succinctement notre association que je
préside puis vous exposez ces éléments
de contexte
j'aurai l'occasion bien évidemment de
répondre à vos questions et de répondre
avec toute la sincérité et les
précisions que je pourrais donner sur
mon rôle notre projet
contester clairement les raccourcis et
accusations dirigées contre notre
association et donner toutes les
précisions qui pourraient être utiles à
votre commission
l'Union des sociétés d'éducation
physique et de préparation militaire si
cette dénomination fait sourire parfois
c'est parce qu'elle a été choisie en
1885 par des personnes qui déjà
estimaient qu'il était important de
défendre la République et de préserver
le lien à l'époque entre les armées et
la nation
cette association a toujours œuvré en
direction de la jeunesse pour l'amener à
adhérer au projet républicains et à
préserver la nation contre les dangers
qu'il la guettent
la seconde moitié du 20e ayant été
marquée par la fin des conflits armés
conventionnels et notamment par celle du
service militaire l'USPPM avait
fortement ralenti son activité et
c'était presque exclusivement consacré
au devoir de mémoire
depuis les membres de l'association à
l'instar de tous les Français ont été
fortement impactés par les attentats
terroristes qui ont traversé notre pays
et depuis 2012 et la chevauchée
meurtrière de Mohamed Merah
à partir de 2015
dirigé par un officier de gendarmerie le
colonel Raymond Carter lui-même
spécialisé dans les questions de lutte
contre le terrorisme l'association a
commencé à réfléchir sur la nécessité de
s'impliquer à partir de son rôle
d'acteur de la société civile dans les
questions de sensibilisation de
prévention face à la menace terroriste
et notamment d'inspiration islamistes
dès 2016 lorsque j'ai pris la présidence
de l'association nous avions inscrit en
ordre du jour dans les premières
conseils d'administration de l'année la
nécessité de créer une cellule de
réflexion sur la question de la
prévention et l'anticipation de la
menace terroriste
l'association apailleurs a par ailleurs
dans la foulée soutenu la publication
d'un livre intitulé vivre avec la menace
terroriste nous avions organisé alors
des débats une large diffusion toujours
avec cette idée de participer à la
prévention de la radicalisation et de
sensibiliser la jeunesse et plus
généralement l'ensemble des citoyens
devant ces nouveaux défis qui nous
menacent tous
aussi dès 2016 nous avons pu compter sur
l'apport de Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui
qui est venu nous rejoindre justement
afin de nous aider à orienter les
questions de l'association vers le sujet
de la prévention de la ridiculisation
moi-même monsieur le Président dès que
j'ai acquis la conviction qu'il fallait
s'engager au nom des valeurs de la
République contre le fléau islamiste
j'ai repris mes études
et je me suis inscrit en 2017 pour un
master en sûreté sécurité à l'Université
Paul Sabatier de Toulouse
ce premier aspect répondra je l'espère à
la question légitime je l'entend
relative à la légitimité à agir de
l'uccepte
après avoir relaté le contexte j'en
viens un bref historique autour du fond
Marianne
comme je vous l'expliquais monsieur le
Président Monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs
nous étions engagés sur plusieurs
initiatives certes pas très importante
sur les questions de prévention de la
radicalisation
j'avais demandé à Monsieur Mohamed
cifaoui de nous aider à aller dans cette
direction et nous faire bénéficier de
son expertise entre fin 2020 et début
2021 au lendemain d'un horrible attentat
que tout le monde garde en mémoire
Mohamed Tifaoui m'a fait savoir que les
pouvoirs publics et plus précisément le
cabinet de Madame Schiappa lui avait
demandé de prendre part à des actions de
contre discours pour répondre à la
propagande islamiste
la première quinzaine de janvier j'ai
pris un café avec Monsieur Sifaoui qui
m'a demandé si je trouvais intéressantes
l'idée de mettre en application un
projet qu'il avait déjà au sein de
l'uccepte
il m'a alors dit sans me donner toutes
les précisions qu'il discutait avec
plusieurs responsables du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui l'encourager à s'engager
dans cette perspective
je vous précise que le projet en
question était très ambitieux c'est allé
sur plusieurs années et nécessité la
mise en place de moyens considérables
notamment parce qu'il fallait investir
dans des moyens humains
par la suite je j'aurais pu vous donner
les dates exactes mais il m'en a reparlé
en février mars c'est ainsi que le 7
avril 2021 Monsieur Mohamed Sifaoui me
transfère un email d'un conseiller de
Madame Schiappa qui lui adresse les
pièces du dossier à renseigner pour
bénéficier d'une subvention
et Monsieur Sifaoui m'appelle dans la
foulée pour me dire que nous n'avons que
deux jours pour envoyer un dossier
complet au ci PDR
j'ai donc dû arrêter séance tenante tout
ce que je faisais et j'ai travaillé jour
et nuit pour pouvoir être dans les temps
avec du recul monsieur le président
je me dis que ce jour là
j'aurais dû refuser d'envoyer cette
demande de subvention
bon c'est toujours facile de commenter
les événements quand ils sont passés
mais voilà non seulement parce que j'ai
commis des erreurs en travaillant dans
la précipitation mais en plus d'une
certaine façon ce mauvais départ allait
perturber le projet auquel nous avons
pensé initialement
comme je vous l'expliquais le projet
porté sur trois ans quelques jours plus
tard des échanges se sont suivis avec
une interlocutrice du cipdr notamment
concernant le budget du projet
en effet nous avions présenté un prolet
un projet pluri annuel car une telle
action ne faisait de sens pour nous
uniquement si elle s'inscrivait dans la
durée les échos systèmes numériques que
l'on visait se développe depuis
plusieurs années comme vous le savez et
ont pris de l'avance nous avions donc un
retard considérable à combler toutefois
la demande de financement présentée au
cipdr semblait trop importante à leurs
yeux nous avons donc progressivement au
fur et à mesure des échanges réduit
l'ambition du projet en diminuant les
ressources affectées et semaines après
l'autre mais interlocuteurs au cipdr me
demandaient de revoir à la baisse la
nature du projet
je m'arrête un instant sur ce sujet pour
dire qu'à posteriori c'est le deuxième
signal qui aurait dû m'amener à stopper
le projet
parce qu'au fil des jours il s'est vidée
de sa substance à partir du 20 avril
comme tout le monde j'ai entendu la mise
en place d'un fond appelé fond Marianne
dédié aux questions de contredours
à ce moment-là mes interlocuteurs du
cipdr m'ont appris que la demande de
subvention que nous avions été invitée à
présenter pouvaient intégrer le nouveau
fond Marianne c'est ainsi orienté par
mon interlocut mon interlocutrice du
cipdr nous avons décidé de porter
candidat dans le cadre de ce fond
et le 22 ou le 23 mai je me souviens
plus exactement
Mohammed Sifaoui m'a appelé pour me dire
qu'il avait eu des informations
laissant penser que notre projet avait
été retenu
je m'en souviens car dès le lendemain le
lundi 24 mai je lui ai préparé son
contrat de travail entre lui et
l'association nous avons alors commencé
à mettre en œuvre ce projet
je signale que nous avons été
officiellement notifiés une première
fois le 28 mai le 28 mai 2021 par mail
et ensuite début juin nous avons reçu un
courrier de la ministre nous félicitant
de façon officielle
cependant le cipdr nous alerte à la fin
du mois de juin 2021 sur le fait que le
CERFA que nous avions fourni lors de la
candidature au fond Marianne comporte
une demande pour les années 2021 et 2022
je le sais c'est moi qui l'ai écrit
tandis que le cipdr et je l'apprends à
ce moment-là ne pouvait s'engager de
manière plus réelle
c'est incompréhension nous a donc
conduit à réajuster le budget du projet
la somme de 355000 euros qui devait être
qui nous avait été
octroyés et qui devait être affectés
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2021 dans mon CERFA
constituant en fait le seul engagement
que nous avions su du cipdr la somme
demandée au titre de 2022 n'en faisant
pas partie
de plus le cipdr nous a indiqué que la
durée de l'action prévue à savoir de
juin 2021 à décembre 2021 semblait trop
courte au regard du montant de la
subvention accordée nous avons donc
convenu de prolonger la durée de
l'action jusqu'au 28 février tout en
conservant le même budget donc autrement
dit en réduisant à nouveau le montant
des dépenses projetées nous avons donc
signé signé ensuite la convention
attributive en ce sens ces ajustements
comme vous l'aurez compris ont fortement
impacté l'envergure du projet
tous ces cafouillages qui se sont étalés
en réalité entre le mois d'avril et le
mois la fin du mois de juillet ont
énormément pénalisé le lancement du
projet outre le fait que tout ceci se
déroulait en pleine période estivale
Mohamed cifaoui et moi-même avions
commencé à poser les bases du projet
durant cet été mais il a été évidemment
difficile de recruter durant cette
période d'une part parce que les
personnes auxquelles nous pensions
étaient en vacances et d'autre part il
nous semblait pas judicieux de signer et
démarrer des contrats en pleine période
estivale nous avons néanmoins utilisé
cette période estivale pour rédiger la
stratégie concevoir le logo du projet
hilaïque rencontrer des spécialistes du
numérique trouver un local acheter le
matériel enfin commencer à assurer la
veille internet sur les comptes
identifiés toxiques ou dangereux
voilà
c'est à partir du mois de septembre que
nous avons constitué une petite équipe
et nous avons mis en place les premières
actions nous reviendrons après bien sûr
sur le bilan de ses actions mais je
souhaiterais d'ores et déjà vous faire
part de la manière dont on s'était
organisé nous nous étions répartis les
tâches opérationnelles ainsi j'étais le
directeur administratif et financier du
projet et par ailleurs le garant de du
respect de la ligne éditoriale que nous
devions préserver conformément au projet
auquel nous avions répondu
monsieur mohamedifaoui était lui au
directeur des opérations caution
scientifique courroie de transmission et
le maître d'oeuvre de tout ce qui devait
être publié une rédactrice une
rédactrice juriste de formation
dont la mission consistait à proposer du
contenu en veillant à ne pas s'exposer à
des poursuites judiciaires abusives pour
diffamation notamment un graphiste
lui-même créateur de contenu également
et enfin deux prestataires extérieurs
chargés l'un du suivi des mesures
numériques et de la conception des sites
internet et l'autre chargé de la
réalisation des vidéos
et contrairement à ce qui a été dit ici
et là la masse salariale n'a pas été
répartie entre Mohammed cifaoui et
moi-même mais entre 6 personnes 4 sous
la forme de salaire et deux sous la
forme d'honoraires
beaucoup de contre-vérités ont été dites
dans la presse et d'ailleurs c'est une
partie des contre-vérités monsieur le
Président qui ont motivé la naissance de
votre commission d'enquête
première contre vérité les journalistes
ont affirmé que nous n'avions pas le
droit de travailler monsieur le
Président on va pas rentrer dans tous
les détails on va y venir par des tout à
fait tranquillement et par question donc
on a entendu votre voilà mais si contre
vérité il y a au fur et à mesure des
questions qui vous seront posées vous
les voudraient bien y répondre voilà de
manière c'est une brève introduction
mais vous avez cadré tout à fait le
début de cette opération et la façon
dont vous êtes rentré dans le fond
Marianne mais maintenant on va rentrer
si vous le voulez bien directement dans
les questions monsieur le Président si
vous le permettez j'aimerais terminer
pour terminer juste cette partie là
parce que je pense que c'est important
vu le contexte et on n'est pas si vous
voulez on n'est pas dans une vision de
par rapport à la presse et les
contreversions etc on va on va établir
nous on parle pas de ça on va juste
établir ensemble la vérité si je puis
dire je le comprends voilà c'est ça mais
je réitère ma demande j'aimerais que
vous puissiez terminé c'est c'est
important pour moi en m'excusant non
parce que vous avez droit à 4 minutes je
vous en ai laissé 13 vous voyez donc
tout va bien et très sincèrement on va
revenir dans tous les éléments du
dossier ne vous inquiétez pas et si
jamais il y avait des éléments que nous
n'aurions pas eu le temps ou finalement
n'aurions pas eu les bonnes questions
pour arriver sur vos sujets vous seriez
amené à la fin éventuellement compléter
votre propos je comprends tout ça merci
mais je non je voulais vous dire non
mais c'est que je joue ici il faut le
comprendre il y a un timing mais on
prend je joue ici personnellement ma
dignité mon honneur ma réputation c'est
c'est une affaire voilà qui était
évidemment
j'ai besoin de terminer ce ce monsieur
en m'excuse mais on comprend tout à fait
ce que vous nous dites sachez que nous
sommes très respectueux
de l'ensemble du personnel que nous
auditionnons nous partons sans préjugés
et nous posons des questions et vous
allez nous répondre très tranquillement
sur ces sujets là ne vous inquiétez pas
et je pense que au fur et à mesure ça va
vous permettra de rétablir ce qui vous
paraît être de votre point de vue la
vérité mais déjà vous avez dit beaucoup
d'introduction donc je vais demander au
rapporteur de bien vouloir démarrer
parce que c'est ainsi que les choses se
faire je le comprends mais merci
beaucoup merci j'ai besoin de merci
vous le terminerez tout à l'heure je
vous donne simplement les contre les
contre-vérités sur lesquelles on a on a
on a on a on a compris et vous allez le
dire au fur et à mesure des questions et
vous reprendrez les contre-vérités s'il
y en a voilà je comprends ce que vous me
dites que je réitère j'ai besoin de
terminer ce réitérer mais je précise
donc vous ne pouvez pas voilà merci je
le comprends je je veux devenir
jusqu'ici et de de m'exprimer
j'ai besoin que vous me laissiez
m'exprimer jusqu'au bout alors monsieur
le Président on va reprendre je dirais
les choses dans l'ordre si vous voulez
bien et je vais m'attacher d'abord
à revoir de quelle manière vous avez
déposé votre candidature dans le cadre
du fond Marianne et de quelle manière
après la garniture la sélection s'est
opérée
première question je voulais savoir
avant le fond Marianne est-ce que vous
aviez
déjà eu l'occasion de travailler avec le
secrétariat général du
cpdr et le cas échéant de quelle manière
question
complémentaire est-ce que vous pouvez
revenir sur le projet que vous avez
présenté par votre association et
quelles en étaient les objectifs puisque
vous avez bien expliqué qu'il était très
ambitieux donc l'idée est de d'aller un
peu plus dans le détail si vous voulez
bien
je vais répondre à votre question je
vais terminer
la première contre vérité que je voulais
vous demander monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Président le président de la
commission d'enquête vous a rappelé le
fonctionnement vous êtes ici en audition
vous allez avoir l'occasion au fur et à
mesure des questions d'aborder beaucoup
de réponses il serait étonnant que vous
n'ayez pas l'occasion de croiser les
informations que vous appréciez en 4
minutes initialement prévu
pour le début de l'audition vous en avez
le Président vous l'a dit vous avez eu
13 minutes donc on rentre dans le
questionnement et puis si d'aventure il
restait des choses à dire vous pourriez
même nous remettre un document voilà
donc si vous voulez bien on reprend la
question est-ce que vous aviez déjà eu
l'occasion de travailler avec le
secrétariat général du cipdr et qu'elle
était le contenu ensuite de votre projet
alors effectivement nous n'avions pas eu
l'occasion auparavant avec l'association
de travailler avec le cipdr
c'était
nous disons le projet je voulais
présenter je vous l'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure avait été soumis au cipdr à la
demande du cabinet de la ministre donc
c'est moi-même qui a envoyé l'email
et le contenu du projet je pense que
vous avez fait passer le le la fiche
synthétique et le et le descriptif
détaillé
fiche synthétique ça en a eu contenu
détaillé très sincèrement non alors moi
qu'on est qu'on ait eu un document mais
qui nous a pas paru très détaillé quoi
voilà ce que je veux dire voilà le on a
eu un document le départ était une page
et puis on en a eu on a eu un petit
complément
mais comme vous avez évoqué je vais
venir avec la demande de subvention un
projet vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
des débuts de l'année sur trois ans très
étoffé si vous pouvez nous en donner je
dirais les grandes lignes bien sûr et
donc
surtout pour ceux qui nous écoutent même
si on a eu des documents vous nous
repréciser le le cadre et les objectifs
de du projet d'accord
l'objet évidemment
répondait aux cadres du fond Marianne
qui était la lutte contre les le
contredours et lutte contre les
distances séparatistes je vous
interrompre vous dites par rapport au
fond Marianne mais là on parlait d'un
projet qui avait été déposé avant même
avant même qu'on vous dise qu'on vous
parle du fond Marianne tout à fait ce
que j'ai compris tout à fait donc ce
projet n'est pas relatif pour Marianne
c'est le projet initial que vous avez
déposé d'abord pour bien comprendre
comment ensuite il s'est transformé
si vous voulez bien parler du premier
projet bien sûr alors c'était
effectivement
c'était effectivement un projet qui
avait qui avait pour objet une une
action en ligne et que l'action
déconstruction c'est pour ça que je
m'étais permis de dire dans le fond
Marianne parce que ça s'inscrivait dans
cette ligne là voilà c'est un projet qui
visait à pouvoir lutter contre ces
discours séparatistes
ces discours antirépublicains que l'on
trouve malheureusement foisonnant dans
les réseaux sociaux et notamment
relayés par certains écosystèmes nocifs
et répondre systématiquement après
évaluation et analyse des comptes
émetteurs les propos diffamants
dénigrants les valeurs de la République
ou diffusons les idées susceptibles de
fracturer la société française voilà la
méthode qu'on s'était donné
en moyenne communication évidemment
principalement les réseaux sociaux
Twitter Instagram Facebook un site
internet
un wiki on y reviendra également pour la
partie définition
les médias mainstream et également des
formations
on avait prévu de faire des vidéos des
articles de presse mais également
quand je dis article on pensait aussi à
l'article de blog au tweet post Facebook
Instagram enfin toute cette univers là
donc l'objet l'objet du projet était
vraiment de répondre sur cette ligne là
dès le départ d'accord donc on est
d'accord enfin avant le fond Marianne
vous n'avez pas travaillé jamais avec le
secrétariat général du CPLR
vous venez nous donner des grandes
lignes du projet
dont j'ai compris qui c'est un projet
que vous aviez en début d'année 2021
c'est ce que vous avez vous avez déclaré
dans votre propos introductif
et ensuite donc vous avez envoyé votre
candidature celle de votre association
directement à Monsieur Gravel le 9 avril
soit donc si je compte bien 11 jours
avant l'annonce d'appel à candidature du
fond Marianne c'est bien ce que vous
confirmez alors je reviens juste une
seconde ce serait vous m'avez dit avant
pour être bien précis sur mes propos je
je sais que je me suis Mohamed Sifaoui à
lui travailler avec le cipdr car il a
formé les équipes
voilà mais ça n'a rien à voir avec ce
projet là c'était de la formation des
équipes d'accord donc je préfère
préciser comme vous m'avez posé la
question si nous avions travaillé nous
en tant qu'association non mais Monsieur
Mohamed Sifaoui
voilà donc c'est des précisions dont on
prend bonne note d'accord donc là quand
vous confirmez bien là candidature le en
48 heures c'est ce que vous avez
expliqué
un peu la Redoute du dépôt de comment
dirais-je de candidature du 7 au 9 vous
formalisez un dossier que vous envoyez
donc directement à Monsieur Gravel dans
le cadre du fond Marianne qui n'existe
pas encore à ce moment là
alors ce n'est pas dans le cadre du fond
Marianne c'est dans le cadre d'une
demande de subvention d'accord comme
j'ai explosé tout à l'heure c'est le
cabinet qui nous a invité à
produire ce dossier d'accord et demander
une subvention et donc si j'ai bien
suivi par rapport aux éditions
précédentes notamment lorsque nous avons
auditionné monsieur Gravel
celui-ci indiqué que vous aviez d'abord
déposé une demande de subvention donc ça
doit être ce projet à hauteur de
635000 euros donc quel est le projet qui
devait être réalisé avec cette
subvention est-ce que c'est finalement
le même projet que celui qui a été
retenu dans le cadre du fond Marianne et
ESCA à ce moment-là vous aviez des
informations
qui vous laissez espérer à une
éligibilité au fond Marianne
qui forcément 11 jours avant ça avait pu
transpirer alors pour notre part on a
présenté un projet avec une demande de
suivi subvention tout à fait classique
le CERFA 1256 effectivement avec les
montants que vous avez annoncé donc
635000 euros
et nous n'avions pas plus d'informations
sur un quelconque fond ni le fond
Marianne d'accord
simplement le projet à 635000 on
reboucle bien c'était sur un projet d'un
an de trois ans alors le projet initial
de 635000 euros comme je vous l'ai dit
on a présenté un projet sur plusieurs
années trois années notamment d'accord
c'était amené à suivre au-delà mais on a
présenté trois années comme ça se fait
et les 635000 euros dont on parle était
uniquement sur la première année
d'accord et plus précisément au prorata
de ce qui nous restait de l'année parce
qu'on était déjà au mois d'avril donc
c'était pas sur 12 mois sur 7 ou
85000 jusqu'au mois de décembre alors
dans un premier temps
il est décidé de vous accorder puisque
manifestement entre le dépôt et
candidature qui était hors fond Marianne
mais dont je comprends qu'il rentre
après dans le fond Marianne si vous
pouvez me confirmer ensuite cela donc
vous avez
il y a une réunion de un comité de
programmation le 13 avril donc toujours
avant la création du fond Marianne qui
flèche
300 mille euros est-ce que vous
confirmez
se fait
que pour bien comprendre la question
qu'on a été en quelque sorte basculer
sur le fond Marianne c'est ça la
question le fond Marianne n'existe pas
encore puisqu'on est le 13 avril nous
avons eu connaissance de ce qu'il y
avait eu un comité dit comité de
programmation non
donc il y a 300000 euros qui vous sont
attribués à priori dans ce comité de
programmation et vous n'êtes
nullement tenu informé vous ne vous en
ignorez la comment dirais-je le la
décision
mon alors là on est en vous me dites
excusez-moi vous pouvez me répéter la
date 13 avril le 13 avril il y a un
comité de programmation c'est ça a été
confirmé lors des auditions moi j'essaie
juste alors
j'essaie juste de comprendre la
chronologie des faits et les les points
les temps auxquels ont été décidés
débattus et ou attribué des subventions
puisqu'il vous a pas échappé que nous
travaillons ici aussi dans la rigueur
comment dirais-je financière et
budgétaire donc
vous me dites vous n'avez vous pas
connaissance de la tenue en tout cas du
résultat d'un comité de programmation
tenu le 13 avril vous attribuant 300 000
euros non d'accord ensuite vous l'avez
dit la subvention il y a pourtant eu un
moment une subvention qui est passée de
300 000 à 355.000 euros par le comité de
sélection donc ça c'est fond Marianne 20
avril comité de sélection 10 mai il y
avait donc trois semaines vous apprenez
à quel moment cette décision si j'ai
bien entendu en tous les cas vous êtes
informé que votre projet d'être retenu
c'est fermé c'est ça tout à fait alors
dans la chronologie parce que c'est
vraiment ce qui est essentiel comme je
vous l'ai dit on a on a envoyé un
premier dossier il y a eu
il y a eu des échanges avec le cipdr à
ce moment là et ensuite
PDR est-ce auquel vous avez des mails
des
mails et par qui vont demander ces
madame Charlotte Collonge avec qui nous
avons échangé j'ai eu un seul échange
avec Monsieur le Préfet Gravel c'était
au tout départ quand je lui écris il m'a
simplement accusé réception de mon mail
c'était vous avez une date non je dois
avoir ce mail c'était certainement
malheureusement ma mémoire me fait
défaut là sur les dates mais mais
c'était début avril c'était c'était le 9
avril je pense d'accord j'ai pas le mail
sous les yeux mais je vous redirai ça si
vous voulez précisément dessus des mails
et ensuite donc j'ai changé uniquement
avec avec Madame Collonges et et on a
été informé à la fin du mois d'avril
toute fin du mois d'avril que l'on était
susceptibles de de rentrer dans
l'éligibilité du fond Marianne et donc
on nous a invité à présenter
officiellement une demande de subvention
dans le cadre du fond Marianne
ce qu'on a fait ensuite et cette demande
de subvention au fond Marianne c'est la
même ou compte tenu du débat que vous
avez eu avec le cipdr elle est déjà
réduite votre demande où est-ce que vous
dites je prends le dossier de 600 50 600
je sais plus combien 635000 € et je le
rebascule en demande son mariage est-ce
que vous faites juste ça ou est-ce quand
même temps vous le
vous le diminuez vous même si je puis
dire à la demande du cpdr alors ce sont
les deux en même temps parce que je on a
eu comme je vous avais dit quelques
échanges j'ai pris la dernière version
de nos échanges et on a candidaté avec
cette version là au fond Marianne et
ensuite j'ai eu un échange avec la
version 635000 voilà et j'ai eu ensuite
un échange avec avec Madame Collonges
qui qui m'a fait modifier alors c'est
pas en substance mais on a modifié
le dossier justement pour réduire le
budget
le 10 mai donc j'ai envoyé deux dossiers
à d'autres proches avec la même fiche
synthétique enfin les mêmes éléments
mais uniquement modifiant le budget
en disant que vous faisiez les mêmes
choses exactement depuis le départ le
dossier envoyé de 7 avril je crois on
n'a pas bougé la présentation de notre
dossier et le contenu on a simplement
réduit les budgets
d'accord et c'est quand vous dites que
vous réduisez les budgets vous le sipder
vous demande de le réduire directement à
quel niveau
il faudrait que je consulte tous les
nouvelles proposition si je puis dire
parce que alors étant donné le nombre de
CERFA qu'on a qu'on a que j'ai dû
refaire
il faudrait que je il faudrait que je
voilà si vous voulez dans les premiers
CERFA que j'ai envoyé la demande la
demande
de subvention était du 1er janvier 2021
modulo les quelques mois qui sont passés
au 31 décembre 2022 on demandait le
financement sur trois ans qui
représentait un million 500 euros
donc ensuite on a découpé donc on a
réduit le temps et
revu le budget avec elle alors si vous
voulez des précisions exactes sur les
montants qui ont bougé je voulais
donnerai ultérieurement parce que j'ai
pas tous les j'ai oublié de nous les
transmettre effectivement avec pour bien
préciser les les étapes
et que comment avez-vous donc
connaissance à quel moment vous-même du
montant donc retenu de 350 000 euros
comme je vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on
a reçu tout d'abord un mail du cipdr
nous informons qu'on était qu'on avait
été satisfait pour notre demande de
subvention et par la suite on a reçu un
courrier postal et maintenant du cabinet
de la ministre de la ministre elle-même
nous félicitants de de
notre de notre la réussite de notre
candidature donc vous n'allez pas
participé à quelconque discussion entre
le cipdr
et l'association
sur ce montant de pour arriver à cet
équilibre de 355000 euros donc c'était
la demande qui était présentée dès le 10
mai
je vais être sûr de bien
la demande parce que on a parlé de 635
000 ça c'est votre demande initiale
ensuite nous on a connaissance de ce que
vous avez une signification je vais
l'appeler comme ça d'une attribution de
300000 elle passe à 355000 et vous
n'avez pas de contact avec le cipdr sur
ce réajustement le réajustement a été
fait en amont dès le dossier du 10 mai
c'était c'était une demande de ce
montant là qu'on avait faite les 635000
était au tout départ non mais d'accord
mais il y a comment dirais il y a trois
temps il y a le 635 000 on a bien
compris nous avons connaissance de ce
qu'une proposition d'attribution de 300
000 vous est faite
vous dites nous on a 355 000 donc pour
passer de 300 à 355 000 on peut penser
qu'il y a un échange d'information ou
alors est-ce que c'est juste un signe du
ciel voilà les 300 000 dont vous me
parlez je n'ai eu aucune notification à
ce niveau là
on a été attribué enfin pour 355000
euros c'est le montant c'est le mail que
j'ai reçu et c'est le courrier que j'ai
reçu ce qui s'est certainement dit en
interne au cipdr je n'en ai pas
connaissance
très bien
[Musique]
donc vous nous avez dans votre propos
introductif
de manière à pas vous faire répéter les
éléments que vous avez donné dans le
propre introductif vous nous avez
indiqué que tout est parti finalement
d'un appel
du cabinet en tout cas pour ce que vous
en savez
un appel du cabinet de la ministre vers
monsieur Sifaoui pour lui proposer lui
demander de déposer un dossier dans le
cadre des fonds du cipdr à ce moment-là
on parle pas encore de fond Marianne
mais c'est bien ce que ce dont vous avez
connaissance tout à fait
alors
donc vous avez comme vous vous avez
alors vous avez donc connaissance de
cette de cela
voyez bien que c'est une une nuance
assez significative d'ailleurs vous avez
dit après que peut-être
toujours dans votre propre objectif que
peut-être si vous aviez su comment les
choses bon vous aurez fait peut-être
différemment mais de fait il s'agit bien
non pas d'un contact du cabinet avec
votre association mais avec Monsieur
cifaoui et monsieur cifaoui lui en
réalité mais l'association dans le coup
si je puis dire enfin en tout cas
reviens vers vous pour faire une
proposition par le biais de votre
association c'est bien cela c'est exact
monsieur cifaoui était les contacts avec
le cabinet dont je parlais ce qu'on m'a
relaté c'est effectivement monsieur
Sifaoui qui les a eu il est venu me voir
étant donné comme je vous l'ai exposé
avant qu'on avait engagé ce type
d'action enfin au moins la volonté
d'aller vers ce type d'action dans
l'association il est venu me voir pour
me demander si on pouvait mener ce
projet ce potentiel projet avec
l'association avec luzep ce que
évidemment j'ai confirmé car c'était
dans la ligne qu'on s'était donné la
ligne interne de l'association d'accord
et puis surtout parce que de toute façon
monsieur cifaoui ne pouvait pas répondre
intuitif personnel à la demande du
cabinet il fallait bien qu'il y ait une
association qui porte l'action si on le
regarde de du point de vue de Monsieur
Sifaoui qu'on espère pouvoir auditionner
ce qu'il ira mieux
l'idée c'est que lui-même en tant que
personne physique ne pouvait pas
répondre à l'appel d'offres il fallait
qu'il y ait une association porteuse ce
que vous nous dites simplement
c'est que vous étiez non pas acteur
encore dans ce domaine-là ou de manière
très très limitée au terme mais que vous
aviez cette volonté d'aller sur ce
terrain là et que donc vous avez
pris c'était l'occasion un petit peu de
lancer votre association sur ce domaine
tout à fait alors quand on parle de
domaine sur le domaine de la prévention
de la radicalisation plus large je vous
l'exposer on a déjà mener des actions
mais sur le domaine de l'action en ligne
visant la jeunesse ça effectivement
c'était un terrain sur lequel on est
allé ensuite d'accord
alors
peut-être pour suivre un peu sur
sur
ce document enfin sur cette analyse là
dans votre association
il nous semble que quelqu'un comme
Monsieur Raphaël Saint-Vincent a été
cité par
Monsieur Gravel comme l'un des experts
de l'association en matière de
prévention de la radicalisation
est-ce que vous confirmez d'abord cela
alors il a fait partie de l'association
à une époque et effectivement il a il
s'est intéressé à ces sujets là c'est le
cas
mais il ne fait plus partie de
l'association aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
certes mais simplement
il fait plus partie mais par rapport au
dossier en question il est déjà parti
quand vous déposez le dossier où il est
encore fait partie de l'association ou
pas
dès 2018 monsieur saint-marcent ne
faisait plus partie de l'association
d'accord en fait il en a été exclu
bon ça c'est un autre aspect voilà mais
donc c'est pour ça que vous faites pas
appel à lui alors qu'avant il était sur
ces sujets là au sein de l'association
vous ne faites plus appel à lui au
moment de répondre cette appel d'offre
très bien
alors sur cette première partie
qui relève donc sur la candidature et la
sélection dans le fond Marianne est-ce
qu'il y a
des questions de nos collègues
monsieur Bacher je vous ai dit monsieur
que cette personne était exclue vous
pouvez nous dire les raisons pour
lesquelles il y a eu exclusion
bien sûr je vais je vais
développer un peu ce point là
le motif disons
très bien très bien merci
le motif statutaire ça a été
exclusion pour motif grave car il faut
savoir que notre association détient un
patrimo des tenait du moins un
patrimoine immobilier important dont
notamment un immeuble un immeuble situé
dans le premier arrondissement qui avait
été affecté dans les années 60 à la vie
de quartier sport loisirs bien-être
accompagnement des personnes fragiles
avec la mairie d'arrondissement et je
vous parle de cet aspect là parce que
c'est à l'origine de pas mal de
difficultés rencontrées par le
l'association tant dans le passé que que
dans un passé plus récent
et si vous voulez en 2014 l'association
avait subi une première tentative de
prise de contrôle
par des membres malveillants enfin il
voulait faire ma base sur l'association
pour évidemment faire ma base sur le
patrimoine immobilier et c'est arrivé
une seconde fois en 2018 avec avec une
autre équipe donc c'est ce qui a fait
l'objet de nombreuses exclusions parce
qu'il y a une tentative à nouveau d'OPA
si je puis dire et
et voilà enfin c'est c'est un peu les
causes et ces affaires internes sont
quand même
comment je peux dire malheureusement
relier un petit peu à
cette histoire parce que on a comme vous
le savez tout un emballement médiatique
et et
voilà ça fait partie des raisons et des
règlements de comptes entre guillemets
qui vise Lucette moi-même mais aussi
monsieur cifaoui qui qui étions dans ce
dans ce dans ce contentieux d'accord
donc je tiens à tirer quand même votre
attention sur le fait que que ce
différent est en train d'être réglé par
la justice aussi
voilà des procédures judiciaires
très bien et donc nous rentrons pas dans
ce sujet comme vous le savez d'ailleurs
aussi parce que c'est un sujet de droit
privé si je puis dire mais enfin ça vous
permet ça me permet d'éclairer un petit
peu le le climat il y a-t-il d'autres
questions Daniel Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président
en fait j'ai deux questions à vous poser
la première pour comprendre
j'aimerais comprendre le nombre
d'adhérents à votre association et son
budget disons en 2020 une année avant
avant de vous déposer un projet auprès
du cipdr pour mesurer l'écart entre
enfin les cas où la conformité entre
votre budget 2020 et puis la demande de
subvention 2021 et ma deuxième question
vous avez évoqué tout à l'heure monsieur
le Président que vous avez dû déposer un
grand nombre de CERFA et j'ai pas
compris pourquoi il a fallu déposer et
donc vous saviez plus lequel c'était
pourquoi a-t-il fallu déposer un grand
nombre de cerfal la demande de qui
très bien alors pour répondre à votre
première question le nombre de
d'adhérents a beaucoup fluctué vous
l'avez compris maintenant à cause
notamment de ces de ces conflits
internes lors de la demande de
subvention nous avions fortement réduit
l'effectif en ayant que des personnes
voilà vraiment
sûr donc on était on était cinq à
l'association le budget était annuel
habituel était de 50000 euros environ
et il est sûr que le fond Marianne est
au-delà du fond Marianne ce projet elle
est modifiée substantiellement notre
budget parce qu'on passait vraiment dans
une
on lançait vraiment une nouvelle une
nouvelle activité
pour répondre à votre deuxième question
concernant les CFA effectivement à
chaque échange qu'on a eu avec le cipdr
dans lesquels on revoyait le projet il a
fallu refaire un CERFA
donc c'est assez
fastidieux parce qu'il se il fallait
remplir à nouveau les chiffres selon les
demandes et je vais même aller plus loin
on a dû refaire un CERFA après
notre la notification d'attribution de
la somme de 355000 euros
parce que il y avait apparemment un
élément qui était pas où je peux vous le
détailler un élément qui était pas bon
donc on a refait le CERFA très peu de
jours avant la signature de la
convention de l'attribution
je vais revenir un instant sur la
l'excente question de mon collègue
oreiller sur le premier point qui est le
rapport financier entre finalement les
finances de l'association et un projet
de signature je rappelle comme vous avez
indiqué que vous aviez demandé un
premier temps un montant de 60000 euros
655000 euros par rapport à une
association dont le budget est de 50000
euros
comment vous êtes président d'une
association
je l'étais beaucoup ici ça a eu beaucoup
d'élus ont été président d'associations
souvent avant d'être élu
comment vous avez pu imaginer pouvoir
porter je pose la question très
tranquillement comment pouvez-vous
imaginer avoir porté un projet de 655000
euros avec tout ce que ça comporte c'est
à dire des salaires
des charges etc
avec
une association dans le budget annuel
est de 50000 euros c'est-à-dire pour
tout dire extrêmement faible
et sachant que les salaires doivent être
versés tous les mois qui a jamais de
certitude vous le savez parce que vous
avez quand même déjà touché des
subventions il y a jamais de de
certitude quant à la date où vous
deversement des subventions que donc il
faut porter un trésorerie quelquefois
les sujets d'ailleurs des humains
semble-t-il des avants de trésorerie
qu'on peut être consentis
au directeur des opérations
est-ce qu'à un moment donné vous n'êtes
pas d'abord vous-même interrogé sur une
comment dire la relation entre un projet
de cette dimension je parle déjà du
premier à 655000 même 300 ça vaut
toujours pour 355000 mais encore plus
pour 655 000 et la capacité en propre si
je veux dire à faire face simplement aux
avances de je vous dis vous avez on
avance toujours des frais on avance la
trésorerie avant de recevoir des
subventions et des participations est-ce
que ça vous a un moment donné interrogé
est-ce que vous vous êtes pas étonné non
plus que finalement le cipdr accepte une
demande de cette nature
alors moi j'ai découvert tout ça parce
que figurez-vous c'est ma première
demande de subvention
sur l'association je n'ai pas l'habitude
de travailler des fonds publics donc
étonné non parce que je n'avais aucune
expérience antérieure sur les fonds
publics vous parliez des dates de
versement j'ai découvert aussi contre le
moment où vous posez votre formulaire et
vous avez effectivement le versement il
peut se passer du temps et
qu'effectivement les engagements
dépendent après des signatures de
convention etc et qui n'arrivent pas
toujours donc enfin ces éléments là je
les ai malheureusement découvert sur le
terrain toutefois dans ma conception du
projet dès le départ en tant que
président d'associations on avait
budgété tout ça très précisément avec
principalement l'appui de subventions
que ce soit public ou privé pour
construire un budget donc à partir de ce
moment là si j'ai un budget construit
pluriannuel ça nous permettrait
d'assurer en théorie le déroulement du
projet donc voilà comme on l'a construit
après effectivement dans les fêtes c'est
bien plus compliqué que ça alors
peut-être juste pour terminer donc vous
présidez une association avec un budget
annuel de 50000 euros vous déposez un
projet
avant le fond Marianne pour 635
000 euros annuels dont vous dites que
c'est plus annuel sur trois ans vous
avez même avancé le chiffre tout à
l'heure
d'un million 500.000 euros donc vous
pouvez comprendre que de 50000 à du
puits annuel 1 million 5 avec un premier
semment annuel souhaité de 635 000 euros
il faut ajuster c'est le moins qu'on
puisse dire la voilure je vous ai posé
la question au lieu des 635 000
initialement déposés avant le fond
Marianne ça devient au final dans le
cadre du fond Marianne vous avez
connaissance un peu après le 10 mai 355
000 il nous a été dit qu'à un moment
donné
il y avait eu une annonce à 300.000
euros la question que je vous pose
maintenant c'est au final est-ce que la
somme qui voulait attribuer vous
convient et ce qui a eu des réclamations
parce que ça nous a été dit donc moi
j'ai besoin de confronter les points de
vue des uns des autres vous-même ou
peut-être parce que vous avez évoqué
plusieurs reprises malheureusement il
n'est pas là aujourd'hui vous même
peut-être ou monsieur siffle oui vous
êtes inquiété de du faible montant quand
un moment il y a eu 300.000 euros
programmés ou projetés
alors ce qu'il faut rappeler c'est que
les 635000 € dont on parle au départ
encore une fois malheureusement j'ai pas
imprimé tous mes formulaires CERFA donc
je vous donnerai l'information précise
s'il le faut après
on a quand même on avait quand même
projeté d'autres financements pas que le
cipdr
donc les 300 55000 euros qu'on demande
ensuite ne sont qu'une partie de notre
budget total et de budget des demandes
de subvention donc ça c'est la première
chose
concernant notre inquiétude par rapport
aux modifications de budget disons le
point pour moi qui qui a vraiment
été un point d'incompréhension je
suppose encore une fois c'est la
première demande de subvention c'est la
première fois que je remplis ce type de
formulaire et je travaille comme ça nous
avons indiqué étant donné qu'on avait
parlé effectivement
sans
être précis sur le montant de
d'affectation des 300.000 euros dont
vous me parliez enfin de la potentialité
d'avoir cette subvention là on a parlé
d'un montant de cet ordre là
effectivement avec le cipdr c'est pour
ça que la demande a été faite avec un
montant de cet ordre là sur le fond
Marianne
de 355000 euros et mais c'est 355000
euros dans mon esprit on était sur un
projet pluriel donc qui correspondait à
l'année 2021 enfin ou du moins de ce qui
restait de l'année 2021
et sur mon CERFA que j'ai sous les yeux
vous savez sur le bas du cerfal la
subvention solliciter 2 donc 355000
euros entre parenthèses 2021 plus 580
000 2022 c'est ce qui permet aussi de
répondre à votre question comment faire
face derrière à la gestion la trésorerie
etc c'est en ayant une programmation
quand même pluriel j'ai découvert
malheureusement que mais encore une fois
après après la date à laquelle j'étais
notifié pour les 355000 euros enfin
l'acceptation des 355000 euros que je
devais faire disparaître ce montant des
580 000 qui étaient pourtant sur le
CERFA et qui pour moi constitue un
engagement dans la durée donc on s'est
retrouvé en fait à voir une visibilité
qui a été réduite sur sur 6 ou 7 mois
deuxième question
au président en tant que tel
c'est-à-dire responsable financier de
l'association Au delà donc
alors vous nous avez donné un chiffre
annuel mais peut-être y a-t-il des
réserves vous avez vous avez indiqué que
vous aviez un patrimoine financier en
tout cas
mais vous avez peut-être aussi un
patrimoine financier c'est-à-dire des
réserves significatives qui peuvent être
peut-être 250 200 000 je n'en sais rien
je vous pose la question parce que ça
permet effectivement à ce moment-là de
lancer le projet sans trop d'inquiétude
même si l'argent arrive un peu plus tard
est-ce que c'est le cas alors au moment
où démarre le projet vous avez une
trésorerie si je puis dire de au moment
où on démarre le projet non
l'association disposait auparavant d'une
d'une certaine réserve de trésorerie qui
a malheureusement été
dilapidé on va dire ça comme ça par lors
du conflit le premier conflit interne où
il y a une tentative de prise de
contrôle donc cette trésorerie je sais
très bien qu'elle est reconstituable
parce que bon ça se fait évidemment pas
en un an mais l'activité était pérenne
enfin c'est quelque chose qui est qui
fonctionne comme ça depuis un
demi-siècle donc voilà sur la montée
disons au trésorerie j'avais pas de
doute alors vous avez dû attendre pour
démarrer l'opération que l'argent de
l'État rentre tout à fait c'est cela
toutefois on a quand même commencé
disons avec Monsieur cifaoui à
travailler dessus des des le premier
trimestre 2021
ok
donc on voit un petit peu le on voit un
petit peu le sujet des
alors il y a une autre partie que j'ai
toujours en matière de financement que
j'ai un peu de mal à suivre c'est votre
projet tel qu'il est présenté il
comprend une subvention du cipdr dont on
comprend qu'elle est l'essentiel mais
elle comprend aussi d'ailleurs vous
l'avez évoqué des subventions
complémentaires notamment de deux
régions
[Musique]
de conseils régionaux pour être pour
dire les choses qui
participeraient alors ma question elle
est double bon il y a un constat le
constat c'est qu'ils n'ont pas participé
ça c'est les documents que vous avez
transmis donc il y a pas de difficultés
enfin ça crée une difficulté mais pas
une difficulté de compréhension et vous
êtes président de l'association vous
démarrez le projet malgré tout vous
embauchez sans certitude sur le
financement par ces deux rayons est-ce
que vous pouvez nous expliquer ça bien
sûr effectivement ce ne sont pas des
montants qu'on a on a indiqué par hasard
des discussions certes informelles qui
avaient eu lieu donc
nous les avons inscrites étant donné
qu'on avait qu'on avait eu ces
discussions auparavant mais encore une
fois voilà ça ne s'est pas fait
nous comptions dessus mais est-ce que
vous pensez pas je poursuis que il vous
fallait des quelques certitudes
c'est-à-dire généralement quand il
s'agit d'institutions comme des concerts
régionaux ça passe vous savez à
l'Assemblée permanente ou enfin il y a
toujours des des
institutions en leur mode de validation
des subventions donc comment on peut
démarrer un projet sans être sûr d'avoir
surtout que les sommes en question sont
quand même très significatives donc
comment peut-on démarrer un projet sans
être sûr d'avoir toutes les ressources
dès l'instant dès l'instant où on n'a
pas par ailleurs de réserve financière
ou d'autres moyens c'est une certaine
façon être sûr qu'au bout de quelques
temps le projet va s'éteindre et donc
d'entrer on sait presque que le projet
va être
ne va pas fonctionner voyez
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire alors
encore une fois moi je n'ai
vous me parlez des des processus de
validation etc je n'ai aucune expérience
dans ce domaine encore une fois c'est la
première fois que je travaille avec des
subventions publiques donc je découvre
aussi ce fonctionnement donc savoir
c'était une telle complexité je ne le
savais pas
merci monsieur le Président Isabelle
briquet
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que vous
n'avez jamais déposé de demandes de
subvention alors c'est peut-être juste
au titre du
cipdr mais où est-ce que c'est général
mais elle sait à dire que votre
association n'a jamais bénéficié de
subventions pour
dans le cadre de son fonctionnement
courant ou pour des projets quelconque
et ou sinon quels ont été ces
subventions et auprès de qui ont-ils
ont-ils été ont tel pardon été obtenue
et pour quel type d'action
alors de mémoire de mon souvenir nous
avons jamais
perçu de subventions mais l'association
existe depuis bien longtemps et je sais
je crois savoir qu'il y avait eu par les
précédents présidents des subventions
mais je n'en ai pas connaissance et je
ne peux pas vous en dire plus parce que
je n'étais pas je n'étais pas informé de
ces choses-là tout simplement que durant
votre mandat exactement il y avait pas
eu de demande sur la première fois que
vous traitiez en tant que président
exactement ne subventions voilà après
l'association elle a un siècle donc
vous de garantissez pas pour
pour le siècle passé c'est certain je
n'étais pas né lors de la fondation de
l'association bien s'il y a pas d'autres
questions mais je veux pas s'il y a pas
d'autres questions sur les aspects et
les questions et les questions
financières
nous allons pouvoir passer au deuxième
aspect qui est sur la réalisation et le
contrôle du projet
alors que sur l'aspect finalement
exécution du projet et déjà évidemment
les éléments que vous nous avez donné
concernant les aspects budgétaires sont
passés en lien avec une certaine façon
les résultats obtenus mais vous nous
dites en même temps vous allez
travailler presque un amour
des subventions le projet démarre bon en
septembre vous nous dites en gros vous
allez vous faites les les recrutements
en tout cas à la fin de l'été après
l'été mais par contre vous travaillez
déjà et Monsieur silvaoui et vous-même
sur le projet si vous nous dites les
choses alors pouvez nous parler
rapidement des réalisations qui ont donc
été financées avec ces crédits bien sûr
alors je vais en profiter pour reprendre
le lapin là nous sommes d'accord voilà
là nous en venons voilà mais ne mettez
pas en cause qui que ce soit dans votre
prouve voilà j'ai dit tout simplement
votre vérité voilà d'accord très bien
alors
s'agissant de nos productions celle-ci
ont commencé début septembre 2021
et j'attire votre attention quand sa
qualité de responsable éditoriale
Monsieur Mohamed cifaoui a rappelé à
maintes reprises que ce qui était
attendu de nous ce n'était pas la
quantité mais la qualité
le bilan de ce qui a été fait bon
malheureusement je je dis quand même
cette toute petite phrase a été par la
presse malheureusement très partiel à
charge en relayant encore une fois des
contre-vérités
donc je prends un exemple
alors certes nous n'avons pas réalisé
beaucoup de vidéos et je vais vous en
expliquer les raisons plus loin mais
peut-être aussi que les vidéos que nous
avons réalisées n'ont pas suscité
l'adhésion souhaité
mais il est évident que nos vidéos ont
été vues les mesures d'impact que nous
avons réalisé nous montre que toutes nos
productions ont touché des centaines de
milliers de personnes ça ça n'a pas été
dit
entre septembre et novembre 2021 en
prenant les statistiques sur Twitter sur
ce premier trimestre de production nos
tweets ont été vus par près de 2
millions d'internautes
entre décembre 2021 et février 2022
notre sweats ont été vus par un million
100 personnes
et puis il y a aussi quelque chose à
dire sur un seul trade du 12 mars 2022
sur la partie du deuxième trimestre 2022
sur un seul trade notre compte a été vu
par un million 900000 personnes sur le
sanguinaire Mohamed Merah
donc voilà cela dit la qualité du
travail qui a été fourni
mais encore mieux et je sais que je
m'exprime devant l'opinion publique je
prends un témoin tous les spécialistes
du numérique que vous pourriez
solliciter d'ailleurs pour pour vraiment
établir un bilan il vous diront que le
plus important pour mesurer l'impact
d'un compte ce n'est pas le nombre de
followers
mais ce qui appelait le taux
d'impression autrement dit l'audience
réelle que qui est la vôtre
si vous voulez nous n'avons pas voulu
avec ce projet faire un feu de paille
chaude paille étant
pouvant passer par la publicité
sponsorisée pour faire un maximum
d'affichage et avoir un chiffre
d'affichage mais créer une réelle
diffusion organique de nos productions
donc bien plus qualitative
donc sachez également que ces mesures
d'impact nous sommes en train de les
faire authentifier par constat
d'huissier dans la perspective de
l'enquête judiciaire et je tiens à votre
disposition
merci
de ces éléments on va on va vous
mettre sur l'écran
un petit peu le bilan global tel qu'il
nous a été transmis par il a été
transmis par vous en réalité
auprès de
auprès du cpdr et qui nous l'a refait
passer
voilà alors
ça reprend un certain nombre d'éléments
mais tels qui vous ont tel que vous les
avez vous-même transmis il y a rien de
truc donc
1763 abonnés sur des réseaux sociaux
Twitter Tik Tok Instagram
500 publications ont été diffusées sur
ces trois plateformes la structure alors
qu'est-ce que c'est évidemment 500
publications
bon l'engagement en ligne a été faible
c'est votre commentaire
les comptes ont été créés à l'occasion
de ce projet et la constitution d'une
communauté là on peut vous suivre
nécessite une stratégie de communication
de longue durée on sait bien que la
durée compte ce type de projet il n'y a
pas de il y a pas de doute et comme
l'explique la structure donc dans son
bilan les comptes toxiques identifiés
par la socion bénéficient des comité
établi agissent depuis des années donc
quand on va dans le bilan stat dans 1500
dix abonnés sur Twitter 428
moyenne de 123.000 impressions alors on
sait tous quand même ce qui est une
impression c'est-à-dire que ça peut
durer une seconde l'impression
il m'arrive d'en produire quelques-uns
vous le savez tweet et je me méfie de
l'impression parce qu'on arrive bien des
fois à des millions mais ils ont pas vu
le message ils ont vu voilà ils ont
ouvert le sujet voilà ça veut pas dire
qu'ils aient lu quoi que ce soit
sur Tik Tok 116 plusieurs milliers de
vues par vidéo diffusées 116 abonnés
950g 21 publications plus de 5500 vues
en moyenne
si on vous met ce que vous avez
d'ailleurs traduire
on voit un petit peu
la campagne digital la plus importante
qui a été faite un hommage aux
professeur assassiné
et donc pour un certain nombre
d'incidents de collège face caméra liste
détecte Victor Hugo etc bon voilà quand
on regarde quand même globalement les
choses
on peut avoir l'impression
même plus qu'une impression
d'un bilan relativement faible
donc je vous réinterroge je le mets je
le mets forcément en perspective avec
les montants si vous voulez nous on est
vous savez on reste simple c'est à dire
d'un côté il y a des montants de l'autre
côté il y a des résultats voilà
le montant est significatif montant du
soutien et significatif même si on l'a
évoqué déjà dans le passé
dans cette mission on sait pourquoi vous
n'avez pas touché la deuxième partie
puisque vous n'avez pas eu les
subventions régionales à partir de là le
projet pouvait pas se poursuivre et vous
pouvez pas bénéficier de la deuxième
partie de la subvention et donc c'est
pour ça qu'elle vous a pas été confiée
mais si on regarde les montants et les
résultats
voilà il nous paraît
effectivement
c'est peu de choses peu de résultats par
rapport au moyen engagés est-ce que
quand même vous partagez cette opinion
ou pas
alors si vous me posez la question de
savoir si nous sommes contents du
résultat je vous dirais évidemment non
parce que si on avait disposé de plus de
moyens humains de plus de temps de plus
de moyens financiers on aurait
probablement fait plus
mais je vous rappelle que ce projet est
né d'une feuille blanche et il nous a
été demandé de répondre à des comptes
comme je vous le disais tout à l'heure
les comptes toxiques qui étaient
installés depuis plusieurs années
parfois même suivi par des centaines de
milliers de personnes donc partant de là
je vous ai je vous l'ai dit et je pense
que personne n'est revenu sur le sur le
fait que l'intégralité sur la qualité de
l'intégralité de nos productions parce
que on a cherché à faire de la qualité
et non de la quantité
ça c'est vraiment essentiel parce que le
projet qu'on avait je vous le rappelle
était pluriannuel il n'y a aucun intérêt
à regarder à aucun intérêt évidemment il
faut faire un bilan mais il n'y a
l'intérêt du projet ne réside pas sur
six mois ou sur un nom l'intérêt du
projet c'est de venir déconstruire les
discours qui sont en face et ça
s'inscrit dans le temps c'est à dire que
pour que vous ayez un compte qui qui
perdure et qui est une efficacité
opérationnelle il faut qu'il soit tout
d'abord qualitatif à ce sens en ce sens
notre mission est réussie effectivement
de manière quantitative on peut toujours
discuter de la quantité d'impression etc
d'engagement mais pour nous du point de
vue qualitatif l'objectif a été atteint
et c'était les bases du projet
qui était appelé à se poursuivre sur les
années qui suivaient je sais pas si je
réponds aux questions
libres de votre réponse
votre réponse j'ai bien conscience de
cette question alors on aurait aimé
ou est-ce qu'on veut aller voyez de ce
point de vue là on a on a fait ce qu'il
fallait
peut-être juste parce qu'on l'avait sur
le la projection précédente
vous en êtes où de votre projet
d'encyclopédie parce que voilà c'est
marqué projet en cours tout à fait
encyclopédie en ligne tout à fait alors
on a on a rédigé alors le problème de
l'encyclopédie en ligne c'est que vous
déjà c'est une c'est une sont des
définitions scientifiques avec des
recherches derrière de manière à
déconstruire aussi tout tout l'aspect
voilà qui qui peut être mis autour de de
la propagande islamiste notamment
on a produit un certain nombre grand
nombre de définition
qui sont une par une enfin vous voyez
comment est constitué un wiki avec des
liens entre chaque article donc on a
produit une grande quantité qu'on n'a
pas publié parce qu'il n'est pas
publiable pour le moment donc c'est
quelque chose qu'on a avancé on ira au
bout de ce projet de toute façon
indépendamment de tout financement
public c'est quelque chose qu'on a qu'on
continue de travailler
une chose que je comprends toujours pas
de me mettre un instant à votre place
c'est
vous nous parlez d'un projet continuer à
nous parler si vous voulez d'un projet
plus réel
qui était effectivement conçu dans cette
vision plus réelle ça on peut le tout à
fait le comprendre et puis ensuite vous
retrouvez avec des moyens donnés par le
cpdr en gros de la moitié de ce que vous
espériez je fais simple et des
financements complémentaires qui ne sont
pas là donc je garde
à quel moment vous vous dites on change
le projet quoi parce que s'il y a plus
l'argent pour faire le projet tel que
vous l'imaginez à un moment donné on se
retourne vers vers le financeur en lui
disant mais attendez finalement le
projet sur lequel on s'est engagé pour
des raisons qui tiennent peut-être à
vous d'une part et au fait qu'on n'a pas
les partenaires on ne peut pas le faire
et donc voilà on réduit en réduit
l'ambition
on se recale on recale les moyens
financiers
le nombre de salariés éventuellement ou
de prestataires
voilà on se met dans la situation dans
Retour à un équilibre entre le projet et
le financement or de ce que vous nous
dites quand vous nous répondez vous ne
répondez toujours en disant on est
toujours dans la perspective des trois
ans mais cette perspective de 3 ans elle
n'existe pas enfin elle n'existe plus
elle a existé au moment de votre
première demande et elle n'existe plus
vous l'avez dit vous-même dans vous avez
fait un CERFA avec une partie 2022 qui
n'est plus dans la réponse donc ça
n'existe pas donc et malgré le fait que
ça n'existe pas d'une certaine façon
vous nous dites on investit pour la
suite quoi bon plutôt que pour le
présent donc on ne fait pas une action
comment dire comptabilisable
immédiatement peut-être d'autres natures
pourtant pas sur les mêmes choses mais
peu importe quantifiable lorsqu'on
puisque vous découvrez la notion et on
peut le comprendre de financement public
lorsqu'il y a une subvention qui est
accordé à une association c'est pour du
fer
c'est-à-dire pour il y a une réalisation
au bout c'est une action qui doit être
menée et elle doit être quantifiable
malgré tout voilà encore une fois on est
sur des montants qui pour des
associations sont des montants
extrêmement significatifs vous-même vous
avez un budget de 50000 euros par an bon
on ne donne pas si vous voulez quand on
donne une subvention de 50000 euros bon
ou de 30000 euros à une association on a
connu ça dans nos villes quand nous
verrions nos vies bon on sait ce que
c'est on sait ce que ça représente mais
quand on a 250 000 euros à une
association sur un projet qui démarre
bon même si l'association vous nous
l'avez dit avec une petite expérience
bon c'est tout à fait différent c'est à
dire que ça se gère de manière
extrêmement précise et chez vous et
aussi PDR d'ailleurs mais ça ça fait
l'objet des questions au préfet Gravel
donc je n'y reviendrai pas mais à quel
moment vous vous dites on va dans le mur
il y a bien un moment où vous dites
d'ailleurs je crois que ça vient un peu
plus loin
dans les documents que nous avons reçu
sur l'idée qu'à un moment donné vous
pouvez plus financer vous pouvez plus
payer les gens enfin ça s'arrête quoi
l'opération ça mais vous qui êtes quand
même bon qui présidait l'association qui
avait été des habitudes de gestion
financière bon moment donné vous voyez
bien que vous êtes dans le mur quoi et
pourtant comment dire les choses
s'arrêtent pas et on va effectivement
dans le mur c'est à dire que un moment
donné il y a plus d'argent et on coupe
tout le dernier jour quoi je fais le
dernier jour où on peut payer et puis
après on paye plus bon expliquez-moi ça
là j'ai toujours du mal à vous suivre
sur ça
[Musique]
les salariés qu'on a embauché nous avons
signé des CDD qui s'arrêtaient notamment
à février ou mars mémoire me fait défaut
mais c'est c'est dans ces eaux là on a
pu payer tout le monde jusqu'à ce
moment-là donc ce que vous m'avez dit
auparavant évidemment nous avons réduit
la voilure de fait ce que au départ si
vous lisez le projet on devait être une
dizaine etc on a pu embaucher que voilà
excusez-moi je vous ai pas entendu
donc effectivement de fait nous avons
réduit la voilure le projet n'était plus
le même était vidée de sa substance
comme je vous l'ai dit au départ mais on
l'a fait avec les moyens accordés
donc ça ne préjugait pas de la suite
c'est à dire que rien nous empêcher de
poursuivre ce projet parce que il faut
le dire on a on a été plutôt enfin la
qualité de production a plutôt été bien
accueillie
mais par qui par le cipdr notamment avec
qui on nous avions des échanges donc
rien ne me laissait penser que le projet
allait s'arrêter brutalement pour moi on
partait d'une feuille blanche peut-être
qu'il s'agissait aussi de faire nos
preuves donc on a poursuivi dans ce sens
là on a réduit la voilure quand il
fallait et
voilà enfin je pense qu'on a qu'on a
essayé de gérer au mieux cette situation
par rapport au fond qu'on avait
bon alors on va rentrer un petit peu
voilà dans le détail de ce que vous
appelez de ce qu'on appelle la voilure
donc dans les pièces que nous avons
reçu on a en fait sur le nombre de
salariés
il y a il y a des évolutions dans la
fiche projet vous l'avez évoqué
c'est au départ 10 salariés
puis 6 dans le formulaire CERFA donc
pour le projet combien avez-vous recruté
de personnes ces personnes ont elles
travaillées toute l'année une partie de
l'année
certaines étaient-elles attend partiel
est-ce que vous pouvez nous éclairer oui
alors nous étions 4 donc moi-même
monsieur cifaoui et les deux personnes
dont je vous ai parlé la personne qui
était responsable
éditoriale un peu juridique enfin celle
qui était juriste de formation et la
personne pour la production de contenu
vidéo elles ont travaillé effectivement
jusqu'à la jusqu'à au début
en plein temps au départ il y a une
personne qui est passée en mi-temps
enfin il y a eu quelques ajustements
mais si vous voulez on était grosso modo
sur un sur quatre quatre emplois plein
temps effectivement on avait annoncé 6
on a fait quatre quatre embauches
d'accord donc dans le formulaire CERFA 6
en réalité 4 et vous dites de temps en
temps grosso modo ok parce que comme il
y a eu des évolutions je dis grosso modo
pour progresser vos propos c'est que il
y a une personne par exemple qui était
en plein temps qui est passé en cours de
contrat à mi-temps donc voilà il faut
faire les calculs précis de de prorata
donc dans les bulletins de salaire qui
nous ont été transmis
certains indiquent que pendant la durée
du projet qui en fait le projet si j'ai
bien
tout suivi il a duré un an puisqu'il ait
été mis en œuvre de juin 2021 à mai 2022
donc à ma connaissance
de ce que nous avons reçu vous avez dit
c'est facile en fait 4
a priori dans les salariés on a une
personne à mi-temps toute l'année dans
les documents qu'on a reçu une personne
à plein temps toute l'année une personne
à plein temps pendant six mois et une
personne a mi-temps on y vient pendant
six mois et à plein temps pendant deux
mois ce qui revient après
comment dirais-je de deux
équivalent en plein et demi
à temps plein pendant l'année du projet
et non pas 4 par rapport à ce que vous
me disiez donc je veux être sûr que les
éléments
qu'on a reçu analyser correspondent bien
assez de temps plein et demi je vous le
confirme dans la mesure où j'ai pas fait
le calcul équivalent en plein mais
c'était les quatre personnes
effectivement étaient les personnes qui
ont des embauché et donc juste pour
boucler ce chapitre comment vous
expliquer que on soit passé finalement
de six équivalents temps plein au départ
si personne salarié à deux et demi alors
au départ
je
vous rappelle aussi que dans le CERFA on
avait on attendait des d'autres
financements
j'ai pas encore eu donc naturellement
j'allais pas engagé des contrastes alors
je suis d'accord pour être naïf et un
petit peu optimiste en pensant qu'on
peut avoir obtenir les demandes de
subvention qu'on avait sollicité par
contre je n'irai pas jusqu'à embaucher
des gens sans savoir si si nous
pourrions les financer si on obtenait
pas ces subventions clairement nous
n'aurions pas pu payer toutes les
personnes
alors je poursuis sur les charges de
personnel puisque dans votre projet il
représentait un peu plus de 40% des
charges totales finalement
dans les éléments qui nous ont été
transmis elle représente près de 80%, 70
% des dépenses exécutées donc il y a un
certain nombre d'autres dépenses on le
comprend bien qui paraît fait miroir je
dirais ont été exécutés finalement
comment est-ce que vous expliquez
puisque on a beaucoup entendu parler du
projet majeur etc comment vous expliquer
que les charges de personnel qui
pourtant sont réduites par rapport à
l'ambition initiale de 6 à 2,5
que les charges de personnel pèsent
aussi lourd près de 80% dans votre
budget
alors vous me parlez de ces chiffres à
partir de du compte-rendu financier
peut-être des fois les choses sur le
même document que vous très bien alors
nous avions annoncé dans la prévision en
charge de personnel
233 600 euros on est d'accord on a
exécuté
193468 donc pour cela
j'estime qu'on est dans les clous
effectivement il y a des éléments
d'autres postes budgétaires qu'on a dû
réduire parce qu'on n'a pas obtenu la
totalité des sommes et notamment
nous voyons sur le cerfeuille on a
surtout pas pu exécuter la partie autre
service extérieur sur la publicité
publique
pardon mais là
ce chiffre 117% in inclut pas les
prestations extérieures
le chiffre de 77 parce que j'ai 83% en
exécution je sais pas si c'est ce que
non nous sommes je voudrais revenir donc
là le chiffre c'est sur les dépenses
exécutées
77%, c'est uniquement la parcellaire
pour dire les choses
également les deux principaux
salariés des opération
ça représente déjà 73% sur les 77 73
donc c'est extrêmement significatif mais
je reviens ça boucle avec ma question
précédente si vous voulez vous nous
dites on est dans les clous par rapport
à l'opération telle qu'elle a été
présentée c'est-à-dire vous dites on
avait prévu 200 et quelques milles on a
fait 160
000 admettons peu importe on a fait un
peu moins donc on est dans les clous
mais la réponse est non la réponse est
évidemment non puisque entre temps le
budget qui était le budget total c'est
considérablement donc la question n'est
pas
est-ce qu'on est dans les clous ou pas
la question c'est que l'opération n'est
aurait dû être si je puis dire de
manière
de manière proportionnelle réduite
Normandie si on dit on a moins d'argent
pour faire l'objet l'objectif c'est pas
l'objectif n'est pas de payer des
salaires voyez ce que je veux dire
l'objectif c'est d'avoir un résultat bon
un projet donc ça veut dire que tout se
réduit de manière hypothétique
vous êtes dans un dans un pourcentage si
vous avez que 40%, je sais pas quoi 60%
des subventions attendues et ben votre
projet il est réduit de 60% sur les
vidéos etc les prestations et également
évidemment diminué de temps sur la
partie salariale or dans cette affaire
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui pose
problème au fond en termes nous vous
savez ici on regarde les aspects on vous
l'a dit budgétaire au-delà des
commentaires qu'on peut faire sur les
aspects qualitatifs mais qui par nature
les aspects qualitatifs chacun chacun se
fait son opinion sur les choses mais sur
les aspects budgétaires les choses sont
claires au final on passe d'un
pourcentage dans l'opération de 42% pour
les salaires
qui est bon
peut s'entendre
à une réalisation de 77%
. voilà ça c'est la réalité des choses
et cette réalité se fait au détriment
finalement des prestations extérieures
de des vidéos des voilà et du résultat
d'une certaine façon donc la logique
aurait voulu si je puis dire la question
mais la logique aurait voulu que vous
disiez bon ben cette opération ne permet
plus compte tenu du fait qu'elle est
réduite ne permet plus aujourd'hui
d'avoir un salaire à plein temps pour
Monsieur Sifa oui un salaire à mi-temps
pour vous-même Christain donc ça c'est
de la logique c'est à dire on réduit
on réduit le budget mais on réduit pas
l'ambition on la réduit dans le sens
quantitatif mais on garde l'idée de
produire et si par contre tous les
moyens passent sur le paiement des
salaires en fait tous
dans la mesure de ce que j'ai indiqué à
ce moment-là on s'étonne pas de pas
avoir de résultats enfin vous voyez ce
que je veux dire
à quel moment vous êtes dit ou vous ne
vous êtes pas dit que finalement le
projet ne permettait plus de porter un
niveau de salaire aussi important tout
simplement
je veux dire
j'oserais vous dire que dans le passé
dans une vie antérieure j'ai connu ça
c'est à dire une entreprise qui tout
d'un coup gérer une entreprise qui tout
d'un coup avait un contrat qui lui
manquait etc on a réduit enfin je veux
dire on a pris les mesures
d'ajustement nécessaire mais tout le
monde enfin je veux dire c'est la règle
on s'ajuste vous ne vous êtes pas ajusté
c'est à dire que les les les
salaires ont été maintenus
vous allez vous allez me répondre sur ce
point avant que je poursuive
je peux vous dire quelque chose ou très
bien alors effectivement je suis
complètement au raisonnement qui est
tout à fait logique
le seul point dans cette affaire c'est
qu'on était
c'est tout ce dont je vous ai parlé au
départ là dénaturation du projet au
départ c'est qu'on était arrivé à un
seuil critique donc je vous suis sur la
réduction du nombre de personnels etc
quand effectivement on n'a pas tous les
budgets mais là nous étions plus que
l'équipe minimum
donc réduire au delà enfin au bout d'un
moment il faut reproduire il faut des
gens derrière il faut il faut qu'on soit
opérationnel donc la preuve en est avec
ce budget nous avons quand même réussi à
produire ce contenu là donc au bout d'un
moment c'est réductible
proportionnellement certes mais dans une
certaine limite on arrive ensuite un
seuil je veux dire si vous avez plus
personne pour pour
pouvoir travailler c'est essentiellement
de la production intellectuelle qu'on
fait effectivement c'est des postes
après à faire une action physique mais
le
l'important la production c'est c'est
moi de vous dire c'est pas une réduction
proportionnelle puisque les charges de
personnel étaient au départ estimé un
peu plus de 40%, elle passe à 77%, ce
qui laisse peu de place pour le contenu
puisque on a bien vu je le redis si
personne vous me dites 4 en fait c'est
deux et demi à temps plein ce qui veut
dire que l'essentiel des charges sont
devenus des charges de personnel puisque
c'est pratiquement 80% du budget
je veux juste pour clore sur ce sujet
donc dans votre projet de alors on le
dit comme on veut ilïaïque ou highlike
on s'aperçoit donc qui a eu des
réalisations mais en nombre on l'a dit
relativement modeste est-ce que ça
explique finalement le budget
relativement modeste au regard du budget
de l'association dans le nouveau
carénage j'appellerai qui est-ce que
c'est ce qui explique
les faibles sommes qui sont consacrés au
final selon moi non parce que
effectivement je vous l'ai dit on avait
l'équipe vraiment minimum qu'on ne
pouvait pas réduire et d'ailleurs je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on a arrêté
les CDD on a gardé on est resté avec
l'équipe moteur on va dire parce que au
bout d'un moment je veux dire si vous
retirez le volant les roues et le moteur
et vous avez plus de voitures enfin de
la même manière
mais par contre vous avez gardé le
carburant puisque les salaires ont été
maintenus à plein pour tout le monde
bien sûr mais nous avons pu nous avons
pu produire et travailler donc je veux
dire au bout d'un moment mais pour des
on va dire quand tous les cas vous avez
certainement produit vous nous on a la
des éléments qui sont des éléments
factuels et on a
rapporté au budget le montant et somme
toute relativement modeste puisqu'on est
autour de 20% alors vous avez la règle
des 80 20 elle s'applique je dirais là
éventuellement peut-être avant d'en
venir au contrôle du un dernier mot
n'auront pas après plus loin mais tout
de même
comme vous nous présentez votre fonction
monsieur le Président vous nous dites
Direction Administrative et Financière
bon c'est vos termes direction
administratives et financière autrement
dit Direction Administrative et
Financière vous vous n'êtes pas sur les
contenus directement bon on sait ce que
c'est direction administrative et
financière qui au final pas au départ
mais au final représente finalement de
l'ordre de 30% du coût du projet
est-ce qu'à un moment donné vous dites
pas c'est excessif et je dois faire
autrement voilà je dois réduire le coût
de la direction administrative
financière si on se réfère à des projets
habituels vous n'en avez pas l'habitude
mais je vous donne quelques éléments
quand sur une gestion de projet vous
avez pour la partie administrative et
financière 7 8 points 7 8% de
l'enveloppe de subventions qui est
consacrée aux aspects financiers
c'est-à-dire avance paiement des
intérêts éventuels et gestion financière
par comment dire par une personne qui
passe finalement un peu de temps c'est
du temps passé si je puis dire dans une
association qui couvre d'autres sujets
c'est tout à fait admissible 7 8%, c'est
des choses qu'on retrouve assez
facilement et dans un monde dans le
monde associatif dans ce qui gère les
subventions c'est un chiffre qui est
très souvent adm is qui fait évidemment
plus le chiffre est important plus le
pourcentage réduit bon mais globalement
c'est l'ordre de grandeur là on est à
30%. au final pourquoi donc pas parce
que
le
travail mais simplement parce que il y a
pas d'ajustement encore une fois à la
réalité des hommes
en question voilà je nous pensons
on trouvera pas de terrain d'accord
là-dessus mais nous pensons que que dans
un cadre où vous avez des subventions
qui ne rentrent pas et une nécessité de
revoir le projet si on veut garder le
projet il faut réduire
les charges salariales c'est comme ça je
n'ai jamais agréable c'est
on en est on en est conscient mais
c'est quasiment une nécessité d'une
certaine façon si le bilan nous a pas
répond alors encore une fois là on peut
discuter à l'infini
de ce point mais si le bilan nous
apparaît pauvre c'est tout simplement
que que l'argent a été mis sur des
fonctions support et pas sur des
fonctions d'exécution de la mission
voilà je je pense qu'il faut que vous
compreniez notre notre point de vue si
vous souhaitez y répondre bien sûr le
comprendre parfaitement et puis enfin je
n'ai rien à dire parce que c'est d'une
c'est tout à fait logique et j'y adhère
par contre l'ajustement on l'a fait
peut-être pas au niveau de la de la
réduction de la masse salariale mais on
l'a fait au niveau des tâches parce que
effectivement au vu l'ampleur du projet
au départ je j'étais sur la partie
administrative financière et chemin
faisant l'équipe se réduisant je suis
aussi passé sur l'opérationnel donc mes
tâches étaient pas seulement liées à
l'administratif aux financier ce qui
fait que le la proportion que vous
évoquez sur la partie support a été
ajustée de cette manière là
je le disais parce que c'était des gros
mots quand vous avez présenté votre
fonction vous avez dit directeur
administratif financier vous avez pas
dit que vous réalisiez des vidéos que
vous réalisiez je voilà alors
effectivement moi j'étais sur un travail
sur qui était peut-être voilà en dehors
des des tâches administratives
financières purement à purement parlé on
avait une partie l'inéditoriale comme je
vous l'ai dit j'en avais la
responsabilité aussi donc les
publications étaient revues à chaque
fois
on avait deux niveaux de contrôle parce
que vous avez évidemment conscience de
toute la sensibilité du sujet surtout à
cette période là donc tout était revu on
a priori je n'ai jamais eu un quelconque
commentaire sur encore une fois la
qualité des productions et le voilà la
partie engagement moral etc qu'on avait
prise
tout cela résulte d'une organisation
qu'on a mis en place donc avec un
travail encore une fois sur la ligne
éditoriale
par ailleurs je participais également
pour ma part à des à des visios toutes
les semaines avec les équipes ou on
revoyait justement les contenus etc donc
là on est vraiment sur une tâche et vous
avez raison de le souligner qui est en
dehors de ma pure partie administrative
financière donc c'est cette manière là
qu'on a ajusté de notre côté merci si
vous voulez bien on va revenir à la
dernière
partie de notre audition qui concerne
les opérations de contrôle du
secrétariat général du cpdr donc au
regard des éléments qui nous ont été
transmis l'absence de versement de la
deuxième tranche de la subvention se
trouve justifiée par le niveau
d'engagement des dépenses au regard du
budget prévisionnel c'est la règle des
60%
néanmoins le secrétaire général monsieur
Gravel lors de son audition par notre
commission à priser que la décision de
ne pas verser la part complémentaire de
la subvention relevez d'abord d'un
dysfonctionnement en termes
d'information de de votre côté donc
principalement du niveau insuffisant
d'engagement des dépenses
comment vous a été justifié le refus de
verser la deuxième tranche de la
subvention de la part du secrétariat
général du CPD
alors pour ma part je n'ai pas
connaissance de ces de ces de ces
raisons
la première fois que le sujet a été
évoqué
[Musique]
pour moi ça a été en
je reprends mon document
voilà
au mois de mars 2022
je
alors février ou mars j'ai je pense
c'est plutôt mars en me demandant
l'attestation alors c'est une demande
que je reçois du cipdr en demandant
l'attestation complétée qui explique que
j'ai engagé 60% des dépenses me
permettant de percevoir la somme donc à
ce moment là on a eu un échange avec le
cipdr j'ai expliqué qu'on a on n'avait
pas atteint les 60% avec de toute façon
vous l'avez compris au vu de la
ventilation du budget ce n'était pas
possible
donc j'ai renvoyé l'État les tariki
récapitulatif des dépenses qui étaient
une trame de ce que j'ai compris une
trame déjà préparée et effectivement
nous n'avons pas demandé le sol de la
subvention ensuite
cette question ne s'est plus posée
jusqu'à au mois de février de cette
année
où j'ai changé avec encore une fois que
c'est ipdr et effectivement on avait
bien convenu que en raison de de la non
utilisation de puce 60% du budget je ne
pouvais pas
je ne pouvais pas comment dire prétendre
voilà au versement du solde voilà les
seules informations que j'ai et que j'ai
eu
j'ai pas tout à fait les mêmes
d'après les éléments qui nous ont été
transmis
vous semblez en fait alors j'ai bien
entendu mars 2022 puis il se passe plus
rien jusqu'en mars 2023 sur la partie
voilà vous semblez en fait avoir été je
pèse mes mots très peu réactifs aux
demandes du secrétariat général du cpdr
au point même nous est-il précisé que
vous cessez de répondre aux
sollicitations de du stretat général
entre novembre 2022 et mars et février
2023 donc
vous venez de dire que vous n'aviez plus
eu de contact comme je vous rappelle que
vous avez prêté serment est-ce que vous
confirmez n'avoir eu aucune
manifestation aucun contact particulier
sur ce sujet par le Secrétariat général
en fin d'année 2022 jusqu'à leur février
au mars
2023 alors je précisais parce
qu'effectivement j'ai je vous parlais
des sujets du versement du solde donc
j'ai pas eu de cette information là on
en a discuté en mars 2022 puis on
février 2023 mais effectivement j'ai eu
un contact enfin ça peut être qualifié
de contact mais j'ai reçu un mail du
cipdr en novembre 2022 au sujet de
comment comment je peux dire ça de de
des éléments renvoyés voilà d'une
absence
[Musique]
à dire que le moi je vais vous avez
tendance à dire que le secrétariat
général
n'a pas été comment dire
très
très prégnant sur
l'absence d'éléments de réponse qu'il
vous avait demandé plutôt alors pour ma
part j'ai eu un échange à la fin de la
de la date prévue du projet c'est à dire
avant le 31 mai ou alors peu ouprou à
quelques jours près du 31 mai 2022 avec
le cipdr parce qu'on a effectivement
fait un bilan
téléphonique à l'oral de nos actions et
ensuite le contact suivant que j'ai eu
c'est un mail effectivement
du 10 novembre
sur lequel on demande ces éléments là
je veux redire une dernière fois moi
j'ai des informations qui me disent pas
de réponse à des pas 1 à des mails à des
appels
à des textos voir même un rejet d'un
appel donc vous n'avez vous dites ne pas
en avoir eu connaissance vous-même ce
que parfois je quand vous êtes Président
vous êtes DAF
vous êtes habitant moi je j'ai un peu de
mal à retrouver
l'intégralité de votre de vos
responsabilités dans votre agenda
j'essaie vraiment de comprendre
alors je bon je n'ai pas souvenir de ces
appels écoutez si vous avez des éléments
vous pouvez me les présenter je vous les
confirmer ou confirmerez ou infirmerait
mais pour ma part de ce que j'ai
retrouvé parce que j'ai cherché avant de
venir j'ai retrouvé ce mail du novembre
effectivement qui était envoyé ça j'en
suis sûr et certain et je me souviens
d'avoir eu un contact comme je vous l'ai
dit à la fin mai 2022 après
ma mémoire n'est pas exhaustive si si
effectivement vous avez des documents
montrant un mail etc je vous confirmerai
ou pas ça ce que j'ai eu donc une fois
que j'ai reçu ce mail là effectivement
moi j'avais un sujet également c'est je
voulais dire la première fois que je
travaillais avec une subvention publique
je souhaitais l'assistance de notre
expert-comptable pour pour pouvoir
retourner les éléments le plus
fidèlement possible voilà donc c'est un
travail qu'on a mené rapidement
peut-être c'est jamais assez rapide ou
en retard mais on a mené ça rapidement
après la réception de ce mail pour
pouvoir présenter des chiffres au cipdr
est-ce qu'on a adressé alors j'ai eu
effectivement un appel après ce 10
novembre j'ai eu un appel alors je me
souviens plus de la date non plus mais
c'était je crois en février 2023 du
cipdr
et à cette occasion là on m'a annoncé
que on arrivait sur une date de clôture
budgétaire et qu'il était impératif que
j'envoie les éléments rapidement etc et
je me suis exécuté dans les 48 heures je
crois ou les jours qui ont suivi du
moins j'ai adressé tous les éléments
demandés
j'ai fait de mon mieux effectivement
c'est peut-être peut-être qu'il y a des
retards mais je vois voilà ma lecture du
des événements et de la chronologie bon
alors
je vais vous lire quelques échanges de
textos
juste pour être sûr que bien qu'il y ait
des réponses vous n'en n'ayez pas
souvenir
donc en mai 2020 en novembre 2022
donc bonjour monsieur
kerdre je reviens vers vous au sujet de
la convention échue au 31 mai 2022 des
éléments de bilan à nous fournir au plus
tard le 18 novembre je vous ai envoyé un
mail à ce sujet récapitulant les
documents à nous transmettre je reste à
votre disposition par téléphone si vous
le souhaitez et puis un peu plus tard
[Musique]
novembre
j'ai donc là je ne peux vous répondre je
rappelle des possibles ça c'est la
réponse à une demande georgement besoin
que nous ayons cet échange téléphonique
lundi et d'avoir les éléments bilans
relatifs à vos actions est-ce que lundi
à 11h ça vous irait puis le 14 novembre
je reviens vers vous au sujet du mail
envoyé le 10 novembre au sujet de la
convention arrivé à échéance le 31 mai
2022 un bis répetita c'est voilà ce sont
des éléments factuels qui s'ajoutent les
uns aux autres raisons pour laquelle
voilà j'ai besoin que vous disiez que
vous n'en avez pas eu connaissance même
si il y a au moins un moment un élément
de réponse à un texto
alors même pour dire que dans les
éléments dont on a connaissance il faut
je crois prendre la mesure des faits
donc si vous voilà si si c'est le moment
pour vous de dire
on a failli à telle ou tel moment on
redit nous on est aussi dans une mission
de contrôle de l'argent public versé
dans le cadre d'un fond qui s'appelle le
fond Marianne qui répond un appel à
projet dont on connaît le contexte et
qui a quand même pour but enfin qui a
des comment dirais des valeurs très
fortes dans l'opinion mais derrière
comme il y a des moyens publics qui sont
accordés on a quand même enfin c'est
logique que nous-mêmes dans notre
fonction de contrôle nous puissions nous
assurer que l'argent versait et bien
dépensé qu'il n'y a pas défaillance de
la tutelle si j'ose le dire et que les
associations font le job tout à fait
alors oui oui je vous confirme alors
j'avais pas souvenir c'était doublé d'un
texto de ce que vous m'avez lu je lis à
peu près la même chose sur mon mail donc
je suppose que ça a été envoyé par texto
et par mail dessus j'ai pas de
difficulté sur cette date du 10 novembre
et puis si vous me dites connexion
échange un texto quelques jours plus
tard oui moi ce que je voulais vous dire
c'est que j'ai pas eu d'échanges entre
la fin du projet et ce mail là
effectivement si si j'ai changé un sms
avec la personne de quelques jours après
le mail ça c'est tout à fait possible
oui donc juste peut-être pour dire
l'action est engagée vous devez fournir
un bilan 6 mois après il n'est pas
fourni et puis un an après vous avez si
je j'entends bien un mail puis bon vous
convenez qu'il y a peut-être dans le
dans le même temps un deux ou trois
contacts maintenant et puis il se passe
plus rien ensuite d'accord enfin moi je
moi j'entends j'ai pas de je prends les
éléments que vous nous donnez
est-ce que vous me permettez de réagir
bien sûr merci c'est simplement pour
vous dire que que effectivement autour
du moi entre novembre et janvier pour
des difficultés d'autres personnages est
un petit peu moins présent ça c'est
c'est je vous le dis donc
malgré malgré cela j'ai pris tout à fait
conscience de
réception de ce mail encore une fois
c'est peut-être aussi mon inexpérience
dans le champ de de
des subventions publiques là je reçois
smiley effectivement six mois plus tard
je reçois le 10 novembre en écrivant au
plus tard avant 18 novembre donc là on
est sur quand même pour moi des éléments
complexes alors il y a des choses
faciles à renvoyer dans dans les
documents demandés mais c'est complexe
mais c'est pas une surprise puisque vous
auriez pu les fournir 6 mois plus tôt
donc tout à fait je j'en conviens mais
je je le revois ce moment là et
immédiatement après ça je peux je peux
aussi vous le documenter dans les jours
qui ont suivi je me suis activé avec
l'Expert-Comptable pour pouvoir avoir
ces chiffres exacts d'autant plus que on
était sur une action plurielle enfin non
qui chevauchait deux exercices donc je
voulais avoir les chiffres du deuxième
exercice également donc je me suis
activé à ce niveau là et puis et puis de
de donc on était fin novembre 2022
décembre janvier février j'ai tout
renvoyé donc effectivement dit comme ça
ça fait un an plus tard oui mais dans
mon calendrier j'ai essayé de faire
vraiment au mieux même si j'étais en
retard
avançons un tout petit peu on arrive le
26 mars dernier vous avez un échange
téléphonique avec le préfet Gravel
qu'elle en est la teneur
le 26 mars vous m'avez dit oui
je pense que vous devez vous souvenir
des
appels du préfet Gravel
le 26 mars je sais que qu'on s'était
appelé
c'était en faut je me souvienne de ce
qu'on a discuté parce que je me souviens
très bien des discussions que j'ai avec
Monsieur Laffite je sais pas si l'appel
du préfet dont vous parlez d'antérieur
ou postérieur
il y a deux mois postérieur normalement
oui donc
j'ai certains il m'a certainement appelé
pour pour
justement la fourniture ces documents
que j'avais pas pu envoyer dans les
temps je pense que c'était le
l'essentiel du contenu je me souviens
lui avoir demandé s'il était satisfait
etc voilà du du projet donc on a au
dessus on a été voilà on s'est plutôt
entendu
je pense que c'est quand même il doit y
avoir un lien de cause à effet par
rapport aux documents non fournis
peut-être pour vous aider
est-ce que vous avez
eu des retours du contrôle sur pièce
donc qui a été lancé
vis-à-vis de votre association par le
cpdr le 17 mars 2023
quels ont été les échanges que vous avez
eu avec le cpdr depuis que vous avez
transféré les documents demandés pour le
contrôle le 27 mars dernier et le
contrôle se passe-t-il bien suscite-t-il
pour vous
des inquiétudes ou êtes-vous serein
après avoir pu rassembler l'ensemble des
pièces ou manifestement vous avez un peu
tardé à aller rassembler alors tout à
fait c'était suite à l'envoi de
l'ensemble des pièces de mon départ par
le cipdr j'ai reçu ensuite un mail me
disant qu'on était on était comment dire
soumis au contrôle sélectionner pour le
contrôle je pense que j'ai réagi assez
rapidement cette fois ci j'avais les
éléments étant donné qu'on avait
travaillé que l'expert-comptable j'avais
l'ensemble des éléments disponibles donc
j'ai fait un envoi assez rapidement de
toutes les pièces et depuis je n'ai pas
eu de nouvelles de ce contrôle
d'accord on m'a demandé la fourniture de
pièces d'un tableau analytique etc ce
que j'ai envoyé
que je n'ai pas eu d'autres nouvelles
depuis
moi j'aurais tendance à penser que comme
il s'agit essentiellement de salaire a
priori ça va pas être très compliqué
mais peut-être est-ce que je m'avance au
regard des éléments dont on a
connaissance qui ne doit pas être
compliqué qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
par là j'ai pas saisi
une association quand on a
essentiellement des versements de
salaire
c'est assez simple de
collectionner les différents
documents des factures
quand on voit d'ailleurs le fait que le
contrôle a lieu le 27 et l'appel du
préfet le 26 on pourrait imaginer que le
préfet vous indiquait simplement que ce
contrôle allait avoir lieu non je
n'étais pas au courant du contrôle
d'accord ok
très bien
est-ce que par ailleurs vous avez établi
comme il est d'usage elle a aussi pour
des subventions importantes de dépasse
153000 euros un rapport de commissaire
aux comptes sur sur
cette opération et sur l'association
alors le commissaire aux comptes
effectivement a été nommé spécialement
suite à la à notre à notre à la
réception de cette subvention parce
qu'auparavant je vous avais indiqué le
budget de l'association et le fait qu'on
travaille pas et justement donc on en
avions pas de commissaire aux comptes il
a été nommé cependant de parler
difficultés que je vous ai exposées
précédemment interne à l'association
nous avons eu un blocage à ce niveau là
donc tout est transmis chez le
commissaire aux comptes mais je n'ai
plus accès pour le moment à ces éléments
parce que nous avons encore subi une
tentative de prise de contrôle qui a été
dénoncé en justice etc aujourd'hui je
dois attendre que le juge du fond
tranche pour pouvoir récupérer le
contrôle et le et les voilà la
légitimité des échanges avec les
interlocuteurs donc pour le moment je
suis conseillé je ne peux pas bouger
toutefois le commissaire aux comptes est
nommé et dispose des éléments
pardon j'ai une toute petite question je
dis pas annexe mais je veux lever un
doute vous aviez donc
évoquer le fait dans votre prévisionnel
de solliciter des collectivités tous les
cas vous les avez mentionnés notamment
de régions vous avez formellement
déposé ces demandes de subvention oui ou
non et
pourquoi
n'ont-elles pas répondu
finalement à votre à vos demandes en les
accompagnant les régions qu'elle a été
le motif
je ne peux pas donner le motif voilà on
lui place des régions nous n'avons pas
ça je peux vous l'affirmer nous n'avons
pas d'idée de déposer de dossiers formel
on n'est pas allé jusque là c'est resté
au stade des échanges informels
il n'y avait pas que les régions on
avait aussi des financeurs privés qu'on
a approché
mais voilà rien à aboutit
voilà on n'a pas été
sur d'autres dossiers
y a-t-il des questions mes chers
collègues pour complémentaires oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président du CEP une petite question
concernant les je reviens un peu sur les
rémunérations
à un moment donné vous aviez dit que
vous avez maintenu les salaires et
réduit les tâches alors est-ce que je
peux vous demander quel était
votre vous-même et Monsieur
Sifa mobile le temps consacré à ses
publications par
journée dans la semaine ou par heure
dans la semaine pour qu'on puisse un
petit peu évaluer je peux pas évaluer la
qualité du travail mais quand même pour
appeler 408 par rapport ça fait un peu
plus d'un huit dans la journée 21
publications sur Tik Tok ça en fait peu
sur une année et 40 et 67 sur Instagram
c'est un peu plus d'une publication par
semaine auquel était le temps consacrée
pour effectuer
ces différentes tâches tout à fait vous
même et Monsieur merci Christian Klinger
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres demandes
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
monsieur le Président merci pour vos
propos j'aurais souhaité avoir un
éclairage
la question que vous a posé monsieur le
Président de la commission d'enquête
concernant la nomination du commissaire
du commissaire aux comptes je n'ai pas
bien compris votre réponse si vous
pouviez la préciser vous dites
qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas pu avoir
accès aux résultats parce que il y a un
conflit et dans vos propos de que nous
avons confirmé j'ai compris que ce
conflit daté 2018 donc j'ai du mal à
comprendre le rapport entre 2018 et 2022
et deuxième question sur lequel sur
lequel moi je m'interroge depuis le
début de votre de votre audition c'est
que vous êtes Président j'ai compris que
Monsieur Sifaoui était également
administrateur de l'Association
il me semblait qu'on droit français mais
c'est surtout très réserve il n'était
pas possible d'être rémunéré quand on
est dirigeant d'une association et à
aucun moment vous êtes interrogé sur sur
ces sur ce point enfin qui paraît le
Béaba quand on est dans le milieu
associatif ressemble-t-il merci merci si
vous voulez bien répondre à Christian
Klinger d'une côté d'un côté et Thierry
cosit de l'autre et puis nous passerons
à la question très bien merci pour vos
questions alors concernant la première
intervention effectivement nous avions
n'ont pas réduit enfin j'ai réduit la
partie administrative financière de de
mes de mes de mes fonctions mais
justement pour se consacrer au travail
autour des publications alors
effectivement c'est difficile
d'appréhender ça en regardant de
l'extérieur en disant tiens il y a un
tweet etc tout cela nécessite un travail
très important derrière il y a des
revues de presse à faire il y a de
l'information de la formation enfin un
ensemble d'éléments un travail de veille
qui est très très chronophage donc en
termes de de nombre d'heures je pense
qu'on a largement dépassé les nombres
d'heures qui étaient indiqués sont nos
bulletins de payant ça je vous le dis on
a on a on a dû
se documenter énormément enfin rester
envahi sur les comptes etc des parfois
des heures en dehors des heures de
bureau donc sur cette partie là
c'est plus qu'un plein temps on y a
passé plus qu'un plein temps en nombre
d'heures
chacun
pour répondre à la deuxième question
concerne le conflit alors effectivement
c'est c'est tout le le sujet dans cette
association on a eu un conflit en 2014
un conflit en 2018 et un conflit là ici
en 2023
malheureusement il y a une conjonction
une conjonction de fait
des journalistes également sont
intervenus avec voilà une volonté
derrière de peut-être
la part des gens qui voulaient récupérer
le contrôle de notre association
d'instrumentalisés en quelque sorte ses
enquêtes aussi parce que des
informations qu'on a averti les
journalistes mais bon qui qui qui ont
été publiés
sans aucune réserve si vous voulez ce
conflit en 2023 consiste en une
tentative encore une fois de prise de
contrôle illégal qu'on a dénoncé mais ça
date très précisément du 25 janvier 2023
donc effectivement c'est en dehors du
conflit 2018
je sais pas si cela répond aux premières
questions
les éléments qui ont été produits
derrière on fait que
le commissaire aux comptes et
expert-comptable aujourd'hui veulent un
vol que la justice est tranchée
avec un une présidente claire parce que
on a les gens qui ont tenté de prendre
le contrôle de l'association qui se
comment dire qui se déclare qui sont
autodé à la direction de l'association
président de l'association c'est quand
je vous parlais de la presse tout à
l'heure c'était relayé dans la presse je
crois même qu'il y a le communiqué de
Madame chappa qui parle de la nouvelle
direction de l'association alors ce sont
des sujets qui sont aujourd'hui entre
les mains de la justice donc de ce fait
prononce leur responsabilité
professionnelle l'expert-comptable le
commissaire aux comptes nous disent
donnez-nous une réponse claire tranchée
de la justice pour savoir qui est notre
interlocuteur dans l'intervalle nous ne
pourrons pas répondre d'accord à votre
question la seconde question que vous
m'avez posée concernant notre statut au
sein de l'association
alors déjà il faut savoir que
nous avions évidemment
pris conseil avant avant de de signer
ses contrats de travail ce qui me posait
à priori aucune difficulté au regard de
la loi française
après tout s'est emballement qui qui est
arrivé en début d'année nous avons
également consulté un nouveau un avocat
spécialisé qui nous a confirmé la
possibilité de de détenir un contrat de
travail
et de faire également partie d'une
association ou même donner à la
direction après je ne suis pas
spécialisé
ni avocat ni en droit du travail donc je
ne peux que vous répéter ce que les
conseils que j'ai pris
merci Monsieur Bruyer pour la dernière
question merci de votre franchise
monsieur le Président sur votre naïveté
ou manque de spécialité on a tous nos
compétences et nos limites moi j'avais
une question sur les statuts de votre
association parce que j'avoue que tout
ça finit par m'interroger je voudrais
savoir est-ce que tout le monde peut
adhérer à votre association ou est-ce
qu'il faut être parrainer ce qu'il y a
des critères et deuxièmement est-ce que
les statuts de l'association autorisent
ce paiement des dirigeants ça n'est pas
impossible mais je pense qu'il faut que
ce soit mentionné dans les statuts que
les dirigeants ont la possibilité d'être
indemnisés pour leur fonction dirigeante
est-ce que sa figure dans les statues
est de quand date parce que j'ai présidé
une très vieille association moi aussi
j'étais pané quand elle était créée mais
donc en général on refait pas les
statues aussi souvent qu'il le faudrait
et donc est-ce que vos statuts sont
récents est-ce qu'ils ont été refaits et
ce qu'il prévoyait ces éléments et à
quelles conditions on pouvait adhérer à
votre association
tout à fait alors effectivement sur la
question de de la possibilité d'adhérer
on a constitué dès 2016 à la suite des
difficultés un comité de validation
quand il y avait une nouvelle demande
d'adhésion donc ça va nous permettait un
peu de d'éviter alors je vais le
symboliser comme ça mais des putsch en
quelque sorte parce que c'est la
difficulté qu'on avait rencontré en 2014
il y a eu un nombre d'adhérents
impressionnant qui est arrivé d'un coup
ça a permis de donner les voix donc de
faire les lire un nouveau président qui
avait voilà et pour éviter cela en 2016
on a constitué un comité ce qui fait que
toutes les nouvelles demandes d'adhésion
doivent être validées donc soit
parrainer ou validé par le conseil
d'administration ça c'est une chose
concernant les statuts effectivement les
statues sont
datent du début du dernier siècle donc
il y a plein de choses qui ne sont plus
à jour on a tenté de remettre à jour les
statuts c'est quelque chose qui s'est
fait alors j'ai pu le souvenir de
l'année exacte mais environ à mon
arrivée à la présidence en 2016
peut-être c'est quelque chose qui était
qui avait été à l'ordre du jour dans une
assemblée générale extraordinaire un
avocat faisait partie du du de la
direction de l'association et c'est donc
tout naturellement qu'on s'est tourné
vers lui pour la rédaction il a fait une
proposition qui malheureusement n'a pas
été validée en assemblée générale parce
que alors après j'ai pas le détail des
raisons mais mais du moins ça peut pas
pu être fait et surtout que c'est un
processus complexe comme vous devez le
savoir parce que parce que il faut voilà
il faut réussir à tout à tout modifier
donc les statues étaient anciens et
concernant la rémunération des
administrateurs encore une fois moi je
m'en suis remis aux mains des
professionnels à l'époque
cette avocat dont je vous parlais a
également signé un contrat de travail
donc pour moi ça ne faisait pas de
difficulté donc non seulement il y avait
cette signature de contrat de travail
qui avait été faite à l'époque en 2016
le mon conseil le Conseil qui m'a été
donné au départ du projet et le Conseil
postérieur que j'ai pris qui m'a
confirmé cela alors après je ne peux pas
affirmer parce que voilà je ne suis pas
spécialisé je peux pas affirmer
l'exactitude des faits mais c'est ce que
les avocats m'ont dit du moins merci en
tout cas d'avoir répondu à cette
question qui est périphérique à notre à
notre mission vous le comprenez
puisqu'elle relève plus du droit privé
que de la question du fonctionnement du
fond et de la façon dont les choses se
sont faites merci monsieur le président
d'être d'avoir répondu à notre
convocation merci des explications que
vous avez donné je crois qu'on a vous le
voyez en deux heures fais le tour tout
de même de manière assez précise du
sujet et donc merci encore et bonne
journée et pour mes collègues simplement
vous dire que vous ne voilà vous ne vous
échappez pas nous allons poursuivre
je vous remercie monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur général et
Mesdames et Messieurs et puis bon je
m'excuse du départ où j'ai voulu quand
même voilà donner les informations parce
qu'il m'a semblé important on a oublié
et on comprend que bon vous ayez volonté
de faire passer un Storm de message
merci merci à vous au revoir